[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
[__] em Friday [__] em indeed happy
Saint Patrick's Day will we get a lucky
Trump indictment today
[Music]
I don't know it seems like the race is
on
the race is on
you indict Donald Trump either in the
Manhattan DA's office on the hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels made by
Michael Cohen or the Jack Smith
obstruction of and Trump in the
documents case I don't know if you've
been paying attention
apparently the staff the staff now and
his attorney
hmm his attorney are being subpoenaed uh
to appear before the grand jury that
Jack Smith Smith has convened in the
documents and the treason case
that's right
oh boy it feels like though it feels
like though Trump and his attorneys have
been notified by the Manhattan DA's
office that they are going to present
charges to the grand jury in New York
it's what it feels like to me right does
it feel like that I mean I'm again I'm
not a [__] lawyer
not one but
his projection says it all and his
statement last night
um
uh where he's absolutely unhinged
and flying off the handle about the the
horse face stormy case
he keeps calling her a horse face
like have you have you looked at half
half the people that show up at
mar-a-laco
have you seen pictures of these
[__] that go down there to
mar-a-laco
who the [__] does he what the how he has
the goal
the call Stormy Daniels horse face
really
when he has the petty Yeti at his side
almost all the time and in Congress
yelling at the at the actual president
of the United States
at the at the uh the State of the Union
excuse me
it's Friday what the hell you gonna do I
I'm not hungover I promise I will be
probably tomorrow though it is St
Patrick's Day
are you gonna get wasted I don't know I
may wink listen
um it may be time to celebrate in this
country I think there's going to be huge
celebrations in the country uh when
Donald Trump is finally indicted and
whether it's whoever gets there first
it appears that Alan uh Alvin Bragg in
the Manhattan DA's office
is closest to strike
and the reason why is because that case
has already
has already been in court
Michael Cohen his co-conspirator went to
prison
for what the claims are that Donald
Trump did as individual one as his
co-conspirator in the federal case that
wasn't brought against him because he
was the sitting president
but here in the Manhattan DA's office it
appears I don't know maybe
that his co-conspirator Michael Cohen in
that crime has given them the evidence
to present to the grand jury because
frankly the statement from Grandpa
Poopypants
um is just his same same [__] different
diaper but it does appear that his
attorney what's his name old Joey you
know the guy that was on Ari melber he's
supposed to be the one that defending
him in this case I hope that is still
the case you guys are [__] bonehead
that guy's a [__] bonehead let's have
him represent Trump in this stormy case
Hells to the yeah let's do that I mean
it's kind of open and shut anyways right
that's why I think they're so close to
striking on these charges
and again it appears by his absolute
freak out on fraud social that his legal
team has been notified that charges are
going to be presented to the grand jury
now
you know this is kind of abnormal
in that normally a defendant
in this case he was committed felonies
and they're presenting those felonies
before the Grandeur the evidence of
those felonies before the grand jury
normally wouldn't be invited
to speak to the grand jury he turned
that down because he would incriminate
himself
um he's better off just bleeding the
fifth in court and not testifying in
court and letting them present the
evidence to a jury
but it appears it's abnormal really for
um
a situation to arise that the prosecutor
in this case would be in close
communication with the defendant's legal
team
to let them know exactly what's going to
happen but in this case they would and
the reason why is because the crime is
clear the evidence has been out in the
open for a long time Michael Cohen went
to Congress and showed Congress the
[__] chick
let that son of a [__] wrote
okay
that the check that he wrote for the
[__] felony is of public record
is it I mean we're not it's not hiding
anything here we're not trying to figure
out what the phone call was to his
attorney to uh to obstruct
the FBI and doj and Nara for the
documents that's Jack Smith's what Jack
Smith is doing and I by the way on that
point
you [__] out there who doubted
Merrick Garland oh boy are you gonna
just eat a [__] sandwich I tell you what
and boy if you aren't trying to make
make good on your past of um calling for
him to resign and all this [__] and he
didn't know what he's doing blah blah
blah blah blah blah listen Jack Smith is
gonna get
staff from Mar-A-Lago to turn on this
[__] can you can you even a man
number one think about this for a second
think about the situation that you'd
have to be in to be a staff member of
that [__] slum right and work close
enough to that [__] that you'd
be in the same room with him when he's
on the phone listen to him yapping
yapping you [__] rage diaper rage all
the time can you imagine that can you
imagine what kind of hell that would be
surely they don't [__] pay enough to
those [__] people to put up with that
[__]
and now now you get a chance where you
have to turn on him right you had to go
and sit in front of a criminal grand
jury and tell them what crimes he
committed while you were bringing in his
diet coke
think about that
are preparing his Kentucky Fried Chicken
bucket or getting the 12 Big Macs out of
the wrapper so he could stuff him in his
[__] fat face think about that
think about the opportunity that these
people finally have
the staff members
surely they hate his [__] guts right
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm [__] off my
rocker here maybe I'm wrong maybe they
love the guy yeah right okay come on
what I mean am I right or am I wrong
here about the staff surely surely there
was plenty of Staff members that have
been dying to let the country know how
much of a treasonous piece of [__] this
guy is
and what kind of [__] criminal and
crooked mobster wannabe that he really
truly is
well don't you think I don't know I
think Jack Smith is on to something here
and I think it's hilarious I think it's
hilarious to the people out there who
doubted uh the Attorney General Merrick
Garland who have been doubting Jack
Smith
listen if you're subpoena if you're
subpoena Target is the people who were
standing in the room while you were
having criminal conversations he has
evidence of criminal conversations
you know that right he's not he Jack
Smith can't just subpoena his staff at
Mar-A-Lago because he wants to
he has to have some sort of road map of
where he's going
he he prosecutes war criminals folks I'm
telling you this the [__] looks
like he eats nails for breakfast
in his cereal bowl I don't know if he
has Lucky Charms or Fruit Loops in there
with the nails but it certainly looks
like Jack Smith Chows down on roofing
nails for breakfast is that a guy you
would want to [__] with I wouldn't
but at this point Jack Smith is so far
in his investigation so close to the
obstruction that the attorney that was
apparently helping Trump with that
obstruction criminally which that that
is very [__] important here
when Trump's attorney
who is helping him with the obstruct
the giving back of the document that he
stole from us
to doj and Nara
that attorney was conspiring with him to
some degree because Jack Smith couldn't
couldn't
penetrate the attorney client privilege
if there wasn't a clear violation of the
law where they were conspiring to commit
crime together
obstruction
this is this is the same importance when
the January 6th select committee was
gaining uh John Eastman's emails and
judge Carter in California in a federal
court said no it is very [__] likely
more than likely that doesn't have to be
beyond the shadow of a doubt but more
than likely that John Eastman and Donald
Trump were conspiring to obstruct an
official proceeding of government
in those emails and those emails are not
privy to Turning client privilege it's
crime
the same way as I told you the other day
you can't hide crime with a confidential
agreement that the that the dumbass
attorney was making the point he was
trying to make on Ari melber's show well
he he can't break he can't break his
confidential agreement for the illegal
payment that he made it doesn't matter
the confidential agreement doesn't
Shield crime nor does attorney-client
privilege
that's the most beautiful part here
that's what that is what is playing out
in front of us why do you think so many
of these attorneys are losing their law
license they're not operating within
their license and the law Rudy Giuliani
is not a lawyer anymore Sydney Powell
not a lawyer Linwood not a lawyer
Michael going not a lawyer
these people aren't lawyers because they
were operating outside their their oath
of the law
they were committing crime and trying to
hide it with attorney-client privilege
John Eastman likely to go to [__]
prison over it
and anyone else Chris Christina Bob Haba
anyone else anyone else who tries to
defend this idiot's lies is at risk
of their law license of stepping outside
their oath
because he he drags him into these
nonsense arguments and somehow somehow
people believe this garbage I don't know
it doesn't make sense to me that makes
sense to you but it's what happens
and that's why Jack Smith is so close
but I believe he's much further away
than the Manhattan d8
uh it is it is uh becoming crystal clear
here that uh the Manhattan D.A is the
fastest way to indict indictment now it
doesn't mean that that's going to be the
only one and really I I believe it has
the um the least amount of weight in our
democracy here's here's what I mean by
that it's very important that I I tell
you this
this is a a strike and aim against
Donald Trump himself in the crime that
he committed uh with the illegal payment
two Stormy Daniels with campaign funds
right strike
now we've had these cases before you
remember John Edwards uh his federal
case where he paid uh he paid to cover
up well his donor paid to cover up
that he had a baby with his mistress out
of wedlock and during the campaign
uh he he went to trial he won
so this isn't a clear-cut idea right
they're gonna have to make a damn good
case and the indication being the
response from Grandpa that at Mar-A-Lago
in the basement videos that he's doing
it feels like and and the statements
that he's putting out it feels like they
have been notified that yes we are going
to present charges to the grand jury but
as far as our democracy is concerned
it's kind of like the 17 fraud tax fraud
charges
that were brought on Trump organization
convicted
criminal tax fraud charges in state of
New York on his business
he's a criminal has been for a long time
he's a convicted criminal he ran that
[__]
foreign
so I don't know that this has the weight
that our democracy needs that's why we
have to continue to push uh for whatever
finding Willis Fannie Willis is going to
be doing down in Georgia with her grand
jury and whatever deals she making it
appears that she's making deals that's
what's taking a while and to figure out
who's going to flip on who and who she's
going to give deals to and what the
importance is of the information that
they're going to give to make sure to
lock up prosecutions of these others
whether it's Donald Trump or state
officials this all comes in the light of
a third perfect phone call that we now
know of apparently Donald Trump did not
know he was being recorded when he was
speaking to the dead now dead uh former
Speaker of the House of Georgia I I I'm
guessing he didn't know he was being
recorded or he had would have been
saying there was three perfect phone
calls he was saying two we know one
famously where he was talking to the
Secretary of State where he asked for
for Brad Brad you just gotta find the
votes just find them anywhere you got to
find them just make me the winner
and a clear cut and if you remember it
was right before January 6 the weekend
before January 6 When Brad rathisberger
had to release that tape on the internet
because Trump called him a liar
and Brad rattlersberger's like I'm not a
[__] liar here's the tape and he
released the tape
so we've had that audio for a long time
for that first perfect phone call
there's a second perfect phone call and
we found out about a third one that the
grand jury has has now heard with the
speaker of the house former speaker of
the house he's now dead
well I mean wait a passed away expired I
mean what do you want me to say he's
[__] dead
I wonder why I don't I have no idea
maybe that's why we haven't known about
this I don't know I mean you know
the clintons apparently have people off
why wouldn't another political family
just saying uh uh
so is it a lucky day is it a lucky St
Patrick's Day are we going to get uh
Trump indictments today from the
Manhattan DA's office I don't know it's
it seems like it's very close now he's
he's he seems like a caged animal and he
knows why He's a caged animal uh so
we're going to show you some of that
today I'm going to show you some of
these [__] videos of him again I know
it's hard to listen to him it was hard
for me to even listen to these clips
it's getting worse and worse Jesus
Christ these diapers are getting
shittier and shittier and shitty have
you ever you ever changed a baby's
diaper or been in a room when someone's
changing but this is the smelliest
[__] shitty nightmare I have ever
smelt in my life
and we're going to see it right here
we're going to show you a couple clips
of it and then I'm going to show you the
statement that he's absolutely losing
his mind about the Stormy Daniels case
because he knows he's going to be
indicted it really seems like his legal
team has been notified that uh the the
Manhattan D.A is going to present
charges to the grand jury now I don't
know if that's today or if it's next
week possibly next week because today is
Saint Patrick's Day but who knows who
knows when this is gonna drop they like
to drop news like this on Friday so
maybe they will speaking of news that's
going to drop on this Friday I want to
give you a heads up I'm going to do an
ask me anything today after the show
that's right on my patreon I'm gonna do
an ask me anything
you guys can join just go to patreon.com
Tony Michaels or go to the Tony
michaels.com click the patreon link
today after the show probably about 30
or 45 minutes
um as soon as it shows over I will make
the link for the video it's a private
link and then I will I will share it on
patreon for you guys to uh start watch
or start you know getting that link
ready and then I'll let you know a time
and the reason why is because I have to
edit this show after I'm done so I gotta
edit this put it up on the directories
once I'm done with that then I will go
into the ask me anything room for you
guys to ask me anything I will set a
time so I will let you know I'll try to
give you advance notice so you guys know
but I'm telling you right now if you're
a member of patreon listen up
um we are going to do and ask me
anything today after the show but if
you're not a member patreon you want to
see what they ask me ask me anything is
about go over to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or go to the Tony michaels.com
click patreon I'm going to make it
available to all patrons this time uh
just so everyone can see what it's about
we've had one of these so I want to give
everyone the opportunity to see what it
is so that way if you want to buy up in
the tiers to get it later on exclusive
access to it you have that chance so go
to patreon.com
and go to the patreon link also listen
it is [__] em hat week holy moly I don't
know how many I don't know how many
Beckham hats you guys sold I was looking
this morning there was uh several
overnight that sold as well and they're
shipping out I want to tell you you're
going to get your um these orders have
been shipping out the last few days
so you're gonna get your [__] em hats
soon
um so when you get them take a picture
for me post them on social media
Instagram Facebook uh uh Twitter tag me
them send them to me that would be
fantastic be fantastic I want to see
your guys's [__] hats as you get them
in because they're they're getting
shipped out now there's been several
orders shipped and they're still the
orders are still coming in so I
appreciate all the support that you guys
had you guys love the [__] hats
apparently so I'm going to extend the
promo code for the [__] em hats into the
weekend until Sunday so go to the Tony
michaels.com click the hat store again
go to the Tony michaels.com click that
[__] em hat store or go to hats.d Tony
michaels.com that's hat that these hats
that the Tony michaels.com the links are
down in the bio as well if you need to
find them down there just use the promo
code hats10 that's promo code hats 10 to
get 10 off your buck I'm half order and
a lot of you are ordering like two or
three of these hats
it's amazing I don't know if you got
like family that wants them or if you're
like look I want a spare I've got my
blue one on today Texas falsely like
blue here's here's the red one down here
and then the gray one that I wear uh is
up there there it is right there it's
kind of hard to get it on camera right
so go to the Tony michaels.com click the
[__] em hat store link and use the promo
code hats10 to get 10 off your hat order
uh through the weekend I appreciate all
the support and man I can't wait to see
pictures of these [__] pants it's
gonna be fantastic fantastic also do me
a great favor here if you would
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
YouTube channel we were we were on
suspension for seven days but you guys
have really came through you guys
followed us around the internet you
played hide and seek with us we're over
at the up wires channel so don't forget
to go over there and support the up wire
go to the upwire.com and click their
YouTube link and follow them on Twitter
also also make sure to subscribe to them
and make sure to go over there and
subscribe to them on YouTube they uh
that channel really supported us through
our suspension
um and then also follow us on Facebook
because you always catch us there at the
Tony Michaels if you're on Midas Touch
Facebook Channel right now go over to
the Tony Michaels the Tony Michaels the
link is on Facebook when I post it on
Facebook
for use on Facebook when I post on
Facebook the Link's right there to my
Facebook page so just click that follow
and then you'll be able to watch the
show there as well
of course we're airing on mine to such
Facebook page also and you can also
watch on Twitter at the at Tony Michaels
pod
you can vote for bonehead of the week
there as well holy moly I do believe
that Gabe Sanchez has power in the
internet today I'm pretty sure he does
so not only are you gonna get to hear
his voice but you're gonna get to see
his see his pretty little Mexican hunk
of love face uh today so Gabe Sanchez is
back on video today that's another piece
of news that we have here at the Tony
Michaels podcast it's great it's great
to be Friday it's great to be St
Patrick's Day even though did you know
the St Patrick's Day history is the
Saint Patrick's Day histories
so little iffy but you know
it's an Irish holidays to celebrate your
Irish Pride here in the United States
and apparently Joe Biden is meeting with
the Irish Prime Minister today
um at the White House you know he's he's
got Irish the president of the United
States he's got some Irish heritage she
likes to brag about it
um but you know here's the thing is that
every day is a good day to drink beer I
guess some people would agree or eat
Edibles at this point in this country
now Edibles are just about to Legal
everywhere or should be at least until
for recreation but uh so today's a good
day to celebrate just for any old reason
whether you're Irish or not put on your
green celebrate I know I don't have any
green on I don't wear a lot of green I
apologize I just I don't have a lot of
green stuff I don't I I know I'm I I
don't have a green shirt and it's a
stone I'm about to tell you
sorry but be be Irish be proud and drink
a lot of beer today everyone stick
around we're gonna be right back
bonehead of the week's at the top of the
hour too don't forget that Boone head of
the week top of the hour we're gonna be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show some people are
asking if you can buy the [__] match
overseas yes we can yes you can that's
that's why I have a separate score for
the [__] man it's a different service
that does that merch for us and uh the
one reason why I selected it is number
one they have the hats that I like these
ones right here
they're Flex vid the hand I wear is a
flex fit so that's that that's some
that's one of the types of hats that you
can get at the buckham hat store is flex
of it but you can actually order them
and they will ship them overseas that's
the other reason why I picked that in
particular uh provider now it's not out
to all countries so I apologize out
there if they don't ship to where you're
at specifically but yes they'll go to
the UK and several other countries
Canada so if you want it's and there's
been several orders uh that way so go go
check out hats not need Tony
michaels.com that's Hanson
hats.thetonymichaels.com or go to the
Tony michaels.com and click the [__]
them hat store the link just scroll down
a bit you'll find it
and you can get you a vacuum hat for 10
off your entire order
just use the promo code hats10 that's
hats 10 for your entire order on that um
[__] hat store so get it get it get
it and and again make sure to send me
pictures if you don't want me to repost
them
just like DM them and tell me that like
that you're just one because I want to
see your vodka mats rather you want me
to repost it or not but if you want me
to repost it uh post it on Twitter tag
me I'll retweet it
um so you guys everyone can see your
[__] hats I I want to see them but if
you want everyone else to see them you
can post them on Instagram or or
Facebook uh Twitter and I'll I'll see
what I can do as far as getting them
back out there Gabe Sanchez is going to
be joining us here in just a few minutes
he's still ramping up the bonehead of
the week bonehead of the week
it's not surprising who won this week
undefeated yeah I'm giving it away with
the [__] you one for me but we have we
have we have some um uh this Alpha cook
that's that's going to be our Alpha guck
this week I think that's who gave is
selecting uh for Alpha cook this week um
she's she says she's been turning on the
internet for like three [__] days no
[__] I wouldn't [__] you're my favorite
turd but let's let's uh see what kind of
news we can find here uh why we're
waiting on Gabe Sanchez uh to join us
what news do we have
um oh yes
this is from Gabe Sanchez himself he
just tweeted this not too long ago uh
George Santos
and
he tweets out happy Saint Patrick's Day
well isn't that cute uh Gabe Sanchez
says I never said I was Irish I said I
was our ish
and George Santos
George Santos you asshat uh so we got
George Santos being I re-ish uh this
morning and then
um there's this video
um for um
let's see oh yes Donald Trump but I
think
are we gonna do this Donald Trump stuff
on bonehead of the week I don't know are
we or should I go ahead and show it now
I'm confused hang on a second let me
figure this out let me figure this out
if we're going to show these Donald
Trump Clips on bonehead of the week or
if we're going to uh do it for it
where is it there's the um no uh
probably not we're probably gonna show
it on bone end of the week and so I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait
let's find something else to do in the
meantime uh because man I can't show
that either God damn
um if you guys aren't following uh
Mueller she wrote Allison Gill
over me ownership you're really you're
not doing this right uh on Twitter and
seriously if you're not a following her
and I think she's on Facebook too to be
quite honest now we've had Allison on
the show several weeks ago I believe it
was several weeks ago ah [__] I can't
remember time runs past here
um but if you're not following her on
Twitter or you're not following her
because I believe she's on Facebook as
well and if you need to find her on
Facebook because I think I'm following
her I think so let me see I think I'm
following on Facebook if you go to my
Facebook page at the Tony Michaels
um you can follow Alice yes Allison is
on Facebook so if you're on Facebook you
can follow Allison too if you want to
find where she's at just go to my page
at the Tony Michaels just scroll down
just click the who I'm following scroll
down she's in that list I follow her on
Facebook as well
but the reason why it's so important to
follow her is because she really not
only does she keep you up to speed on
some uh the the news that is happening
because you see she's quote treating uh
Scott McFarland also a a friend of the
show here he's always tweeting and he's
we use his tweets here
um special counsel probing classified
documents seeking question to question
Trump's attorney sources say this is a
CBS News article this Evan Corcoran
Coran Corcoran is it Corker and I don't
give a [__] [__]
um he he was the one that took the call
around the investigation of the stolen
documents and apparently and probably at
the behest of the former gay
the Cheeto dust mobster or Cheeto dusk q
and R as he now is known Grandpa poopy
pants probably has committed obstruction
himself because he knew he was
obstructing and he knew Trump was
obstructing attorneys can't do that it's
not a thing they can do and it isn't
protected by attorney client privilege
when you're committing oh what's that
thing called crime
um so uh like Allison points out in
order to pierce attorney-client
privilege using the crime fraud
exception right that's the crime fraud
exception
which is what Jack Smith is trying to
use
um now there's a lot of these battles
that are happening under seal and if you
read the thread here by Allison she kind
of explains that right
um but the reporting is is that Geo doj
would have to provide evidence that
Cochrane and Trump more than likely and
not
right communicated in a furtherance of a
crime meaning they were trying they were
more than likely knowingly obstructing
and they knew they were obstructing
which is a crime so when you try to hide
a crime under the attorney-client
privilege
prosecutors can use what they call the
crime fraud exception
to seek that evidence and and get it out
of attorney-client privilege where it
can be used in court
against the defendant so uh thank you
Allison for always keeping us feet and
again she has a she has a whole thread
here on this
and several tweets she's explaining it
but I I think I did a pretty good job of
giving a synopsis there so go go file
Alice and go read that thread and and I
think she she has you know a podcast
herself a couple of them actually she
has one on Jack Smith that she's doing
with Andrew McCabe
um and of course Mueller she wrote and
and
um daily beans pod
um and you can go to Mueller she
wrote.com so
um I appreciate Allison and all the work
she does and and keeping us up to speed
uh she's one of the accounts that I
follow to to keep this news straight to
be quite honest with you okay okay okay
oh man
we're definitely not going to get to
this in the uh in The Bona of the week
so let me show you this Patriot takes
post this uh video now this video was
posted the other day I think um
I think it was Ron filenkowski posted
this video of Ron DeSantis uh changing
his La how he says his last name over
time right and and really honestly a lot
of Republicans came to Rhonda Santos's
De Santos as I call him
um he came to his defense but patriotic
points out Trump posted video claiming
Ron DeSantis
changed how he pronounces his last name
so this is the video
that the former guy the Cheeto does
Cuban honor Grandpa Poopypants posted on
fraud social this is a this is a capture
of it listen to how Rhonda santis D
santis DeSantis De Santos says his last
name Andy Santos I'm rondi santis I am
Ron DeSantis this is Governor Ron
DeSantis hello this is Governor Ron
DeSantis wishing everyone a Merry
Christmas hi this is Governor Ron
DeSantis and I want to wish you a Happy
Thanksgiving hi I'm Governor Ron
DeSantis and I want to congratulate all
of you at Rumble as you open your U.S
D santis he used to put a lot on Amazon
the D part maybe he's maybe he thought
it made him um appear to have a big D
when he emphasized the D I don't know uh
Ronnie tiny D though has been changing
how he says his name over time
apparently but uh here's he
Trump just like uh repost this [__] on
front social right because Johnny manga
I'm not [__] you with a blue check
look at that Johnny Maga with a blue
chick
[Music]
oh there's such the [__] parody of
themselves uh I mean look at that look
at the [__] Avatar that it's got come
on man come on
what the [__] is going on over there
um
Johnny Maga says about this video who
changes the pronunciation of their own
last name in their 40s is there anything
genuine about this guy I don't know if
you know this but I have been telling
you
for a while now that Rhonda Santos is
not going to be able to get in this race
and his window is closing Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter and Tighter every
[__] minute that Donald Trump attacks
him and we should be encouraging it
folks now I want him to get in don't
again I'm gonna say this time and time
and time again until we get to this
point I want Ron DeSantis to get in it's
very important
it's very important
I want him to get in
so Donald Trump can crush his political
career because he will he'll destroy him
he'll [__] destroy him
but I don't think he actually gets in I
think he's too much of a [__] ass [__]
to be quite honest with you
he's weak he's feeble he's not the
charismatic person that you think he is
again everyone thought Scott Walker the
former governor of Wisconsin was going
to be oh he's going to be great he's
going to kick ass he's going to be the
greatest president of all time and he
couldn't make it out of Iowa
and Iowa borders Wisconsin I mean
Wisconsin's like Northern Iowa right oh
[__] get the [__] out of here okay I
want to show you another video that I
found the day and Chris Evans had this
post I think we've actually showed par
parts of this on on the show already but
this is too hilarious not to show this
is too hilarious not to show and then
and then I got him speaking of um
hilarious videos I got a video I want to
show you Michael Knowles do you remember
Michael Knowles do you remember the
daily wire that [__] that [__]
fascist rag that Nazi Michael Knowles
went on stage and said he wanted to
eradicate transgender people do you
remember that
you remember oh man and then those Nazis
showed up the Nazis showed up in
matching uniforms in Ohio Wadsworth Ohio
to protest a costume entertainment show
do you remember the drag show yeah uh
daily wire that Nazi rag really
encouraging neo-nazis to dress up in
matching uniforms to go protest a
costume show a drag show in Ohio
did I say Iowa first I may have misspoke
Ohio Wadsworth Ohio not Iowa Ohio
but I'm gonna you remember that guy
right not Michael Knowles you remember
this I mean you know
he's kind of forgettable but he is
becoming a more prominent Nazi as the
daily wire the Nazi Rag and the Nazi
network is really presenting him as
someone who wants to eradicate
transgender people they love those guys
I mean Candace Owens uh Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro they want to eradicate
transgender people
and frankly um Charlie Kirk has been
accused of wanting them to be lynched
I mean to tell me that that's wrong tell
me that it's wrong that that Charlie
Kirk has not wanted that he doesn't want
transgender people to be lynched or that
daily wire wants them to be eradicated
but listen to this year this is a great
video of an exchange about
someone who's against against
transgender people they can't figure out
why but listen here this genderism is
where the person feels that they will
find happiness through emulating their
body okay so uh I'm gonna stop there
because and I'm gonna back it up because
I want you to listen to how he says it
in the beginning okay listen to how he
said listen to how they're dehumanizing
these people okay because this is very
[__] important this is the same
language Michael moles used on stage at
CPAC when he called for the eradication
of transgender people that's right
Michael hey Michael I'm saying you
called for them the people to be
eradicated I don't care what words you
used I don't give a [__] what words you
used you're calling for them to be
eradicated but listen to the beginning
of this video he doesn't say transgender
people he says transgenderism listen
again this genderism is where the person
feels that they will find happiness
through mutilating their body a girl in
my yoga class got a boob job no no that
would be completely different from
transgender which is oh yeah you need to
be the opposite sex in order to
find happiness so he's saying that that
pretending to pretending quote when you
when you actually what he calls
mutilation but you go through a
transformation from either male to
female female to male right
um he's calling mutilation which is the
wrong phrasing he's a [__] bonehead
he's wrong he's factually inaccurate
here right he's an idiot he's a bigot
what I mean
I'm not trying to make excuses for him
that's just what he is he's a white male
straight bigot
now
he says he says that pretending to be
the opposite sex
in order to find happiness is
transgenderism listen to these words
this is I know it
um sounds like I'm picking this apart
but I'm telling you this transgenderism
as opposed to saying transgender people
um these language is important what
they're picking out how they're saying
it right uh pretending to be the
opposite sex in order to find happiness
okay now
um I don't know if you're aware there's
a document out there that our country's
founded on and I believe it says in
there
um it may say
I don't know if it's a quote a direct
quote but it might be the pursuit of
happiness I believe is the words of
Thomas Jefferson maybe I'm wrong I don't
know maybe I'm just maybe I'm crazy but
listen to how she rebutts this is
beautiful so the problem is people doing
things to find happiness
um oh it comes from a breakdown actually
it's a breakdown of the family unit do
you have a wife no kids no but I'm
worried about something for children
throughout our state and Nation I mean
come on really he has no wife he has no
kids but he's worried he's worried about
the breakdown of the family unit and
this guy can't even muster up enough
[__] social in awkwardness or a
social social acceptance to dampen his
social and awkward and awkwardness to to
have his own family unit but he's
worried about other family units [__]
out of here this is fascism 101 where
they're worried about your [__] not
their own mind mind your [__]
business let's let's continue this is
great she does a great job by the way
keep going so you're doing everything in
your power to protect children from
other grown men besides yourself well
and he doesn't even know what's
happening really until
um this next question that she asked
like she has he has no clue that he's
painting himself into a corner and it's
very obvious that everything he's saying
is projection and she's making it that
that obvious but watch they'll they'll
they'll put it as
you have no children so why are you
interested in children you can be
interested in children for other reasons
than because you have them right some of
those reasons are illegal
[Music]
some of those reasons
are illegal oh my God I I can't hardly I
can't hardly Tell You Hell
how great that video makes me feel now
again what you need to do because I know
you get some stupid [__] Uncle Earl
out there that says this same exact [__]
oh well there it is pretending to be the
opposite sex blah blah blah
go watch this video use those arguments
because it will absolutely turn your
Uncle Earl into this guy now
um I told you
um in the lead up of that video then I
had a video of Michael Knowles and I do
I have a video of Michael Knowles now
this video I do I don't think
I don't think this video
is from PornHub okay I don't think it is
now I'm I'm not really sure what kind of
acting career Michael Knowles had before
I know last night that I I think after
this video appeared on the internet uh
our great co-host and executive producer
Gabe Sanchez
um
he did a little bit of research to find
out what kind of acting career Michael
Mills might have had but this video here
again I'm not sure what the movie is I'm
not sure what the film is I don't know
if it's porn or not I'm not real sure
and really honestly I I think
other than the shitty acting because
it's no wonder Michael Knowles doesn't
have an acting career he's a really
shitty actor I mean you'll see it in
this clip he's [__] horrible it ain't
no wonder that that he doesn't have an
acting career
but besides that the the way the film is
made the lighting it's [__]
I mean it's just all around [__] now
it's like a independent uh film or
something it's like a short film
um but she'll never believe you'll never
believe what my the character that
Michael Noel has to play in this in this
video why don't I just show it to you
and you see if you can spot Michael
moles and what's happening now again
I'm telling you I other than this
clipping really shitty [__] the lighting
shitty the camera Works shitty the shots
are shitty the lit the uh the dialogue
is shitty the acting is horrible
delivery is even worse
um but I mean maybe the blotline's
decent you know I I don't know right
[__] I don't know and really
um an acting job as an acting job most
the time in Hollywood so who am I to
blame Michael Knowles for being in the
short film I don't know maybe maybe it
was a good short film I haven't seen the
whole thing but what makes me really
question this
is maybe maybe the reason why Michael
Knowles
is such a [__] bigot towards the
lgbtq community and in particular the
the trans Community
um confusing drag shows and trans he
does that in his mind he gets a lot of
confusion I think that confusion I don't
know may have came from his acting
career because I don't believe here
listen I do not believe that if you um
if you are acting in your professional
acting and you pretend to be a character
that you are that character right but I
mean maybe just maybe Michael Knowles
has such a weak little mind that maybe
he doesn't know the difference and he
got confused that's why he's such a
[__] Nazi now I don't know I'd have
to interview him I'd have to talk to
Michael even though it would be very
difficult for me to do in person
for reasons that you could probably
understand
let's watch this clip this is Michael
moles here see if you can spot him
that was
wow wow thanks have you not done it with
me if we don't get into that oh yeah
sure sure
say I don't know if you're I don't know
if you know where this is going or not
but uh it feels like to me it feels like
to me that Michael Knowles the character
that he's playing here has just had sex
with this man now we didn't see the clip
before right it's clipped right at this
moment and right wing cope on Twitter
hand this video and I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you a view of the the comments and
stuff and I'm going to show you a few
screenshot still shots of this video but
let's let's continue here let's see what
else happens let's see what else happens
in this
um historic short film that Michael
Knowles
starred in in his early acting career
before he became a Nazi it's uh that's
that's not a lot is it
can I get a towel
[Laughter]
oh man
oh my God asking for a towel see the
shots the shots are horrible the
lighting's horrible the miking is just
awful in this
because you can hear you can hear the
buzzing in the background right
the awkwardness
yeah
he's got the towel now he's got the
towel I I apologize for this but we
gotta I gotta show you I gotta go to the
end here because uh whoa whoa what was
that
oh
yep okay I want my number yeah um yeah
uh sure it feels like you know hang on a
second it feels like the other actor in
this uh playing the character it feels
like to me that he's very uncomfortable
with Michael Knowles character and I'm
not sure I'm not sure if the actor who's
playing the other character here
um is acting so awkward because of
Michael Knowles character or maybe
I'm just maybe just because that's just
the way it worked out in the scene
because maybe he was a little worried
about Michael Knowles the actor not
necessarily his character I don't know
beats me I guess we'll never know
it's very awkward
the shots are horrible did you notice
that the [__] angles and [__] are
horrible
they're using one camera but they they
could have shot this scene a couple
different times and edit it to where
there was a couple different shots in it
right now he's biting his bottom limp
boy he's really boy he's into this he's
into this character right he's really
gotten it's almost like method acting
here
now listen to the line that he has when
he leaves
[Music]
[Applause]
that just happened
that just happened now again these lines
could have been written for Michael
Knowles I don't know I don't know they
Knowles and he's just reciting them the
way that the script said or he could be
in doing improvisation right he could
have been improving these lines but it
really does
um it really does
really that's piss you off doesn't it
then it just pissed you off when when
this [__] this [__]
Nazi Michael Knowles
and and and the guy in the video before
right because this is this is this is
important and I know you feel you're
saying well it's he was acting right he
was acting how can you accuse him of
being I'm not accusing him being
homosexual by the way I don't actually
believe this proves anything about
Michael Knowles sexuality nothing
absolutely nothing just like just like
when someone dresses up and drag it
doesn't prove anything about their
sexual orientation or their gender or
the way they identify okay it's their
Liberty it's their freedom to do that to
dress up and drag and have a drag show
or dress up and drag and read stories to
children to get them to encourage them
to read
right
same way it's Michael Knowles Liberty to
act to act and and and to act in a movie
where he would play a gay man right
that's his [__] even if he isn't a
gay man that's his [__] Liberty
that's the right you end this country
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
but this this [__] coward this Nazi
[__] coward Michael moles who goes on
that Nazi rag every [__] day daily
wire to a call for the extermination and
genocide of transgender people because
like the guy in the video before said
they're pretending to be the opposite
sex here Michael moles is pretending to
be a member of the lgbtq community
on film probably paid to do it to
pretend to be exercising his [__]
right and Liberty to do that
and you're good you're gonna you're
gonna [__] call for the extermination
extermination of other [__] the
[__] out of here with that nonsense you
you pile of [__] [__]
this is more of I want for me and not
for thee that's right Michael Knowles
wants the Liberty to go act in a short
film and pretend or whatever to act in a
film
Mike he's a like he's a gay man
but he doesn't want the he doesn't want
other folks to have the Liberty to dress
up
and have a performance
do you do you do you see why this is so
[__] infuriating
do you understand why Michael Knowles is
trying to take advantage of his white
male privilege
it's [__] sickening it's [__]
sickening now uh right-wing cope is the
one who posted this again it says I just
found an old short film
and Michael Knowles acted in the current
headliner of the conservative homophobia
and transphobia played
a gay twink
so much for restoring traditional
masculinity and again it doesn't make
Michael Knowles
playing
a gay dude in a short film doesn't make
him gay
okay it's acting right it's acting just
like dressing in drag doesn't make you
trans doesn't necessarily make you gay
it's it's it's a performance you [__]
idiots
now
to call for the extermination of a group
of people
because you're confused about what a
drag queen is because you're not aware
of I don't know facts
and to be encouraging Nazis to go to
Ohio and I don't care what you say I
don't give a [__] what you say daily
wire Matt Walsh
Ben Shapiro Charlie Kirk at turning
points USA and especially Michael moles
getting on the seat pack stage and
saying he wants to eradicate transgender
people
when he damn well knows he's trying to
make drag queens somehow transgender
people and somehow transgender people
are bad which doesn't make any [__]
sense
and that makes Tran drag bad and they're
just they're confused they're [__]
confused
and it it really shows you it really
shows you where maybe Michael Knowles
confusion comes from
maybe that's where it comes from is he's
just absolutely confused in his own
little [__] Nazi P brain of his and
[__] piece of [__] now I want to show
you
um
because
I pointed it out when the video was
playing
and I don't know if this was costuming
or if this just happened to be
the pair undies that Michael Knowles had
on that day I would imagine that
um
I want to imagine because William legate
points out here he says bro now this is
a screenshot of this here is the the
point in the film were
Michael Knowles character is getting out
of bed and you can see the the undies
here again you know I I don't care what
kind of underwear someone wears whatever
and maybe this is costuming at its best
it's possible
it's possible this is casting me at its
best Maybe
could be
possibly
I don't know I just want to point that
out as well
oh my God
what do you what are you gonna do I
don't make this [__] up I just I'm here
to tell you about it I don't know what
you want me to do
I know what you want me to do I gotta
hold these Nazis accountable we have and
I know it feels like all it is is kind
of trivial no it is not trivial
it is not my contributor trivial these
people these [__] Nazis are calling
for the extermination the genocide and
the eradication of your fellow
countrymen
and if they succeed which I don't
believe they will because we have a huge
Coalition against them
that is for democracy that is for
Liberty but if they succeed in the
stripping away
women's rights even further transgender
rights even further lgbtq Community
rights team further people of colors
rights even further they're gonna come
after you
they're common for you too they won't
stop
they will not stop until this country is
only filled with people who believe in
the [__] they believe
which is bigotry and nonsense but that's
just the way it is now let's see I think
Gabe Sanchez is going to be um joining
us here in just a second
what else do we got going on do I have
another clip I'm trying to
be honest with you I'm trying to stall
here because I I really want to show
these um oh here we go
I found one we can play
this is Julie green she's supposedly a
prophet
this is some crazy ass [__] this is some
crazy [__] now you notice a few things
about this video right she always has
this clock in the background it's like a
a digital world clock or some [__] right
it has the day the time the date right
so she's always proving what the time
stamp of this video is because she's a
prophet like she she literally people
think this this [__] crazy this crazy
Karen speaks to God I'm not [__] you
they people believe that her crazy ass
speaks to God
and then she comes on her show and says
in the microphone what God tells her
maybe I don't know maybe that's a good
stick should I should I do that should I
be like oh yeah Satan Satan let me know
this he said this let me read you the
statement that he sent down that he
faxed to me I'll read the effects from
Satan right should I do that I don't
know I'm just saying maybe to be good
for views good for clicks I mean this
lady's making that hell this lady's
making a good grift I mean Todd points
out a good point here on um on YouTube
She's a grifter maybe it's a good grift
I don't know could be
maybe I should start getting faxes from
Satan I don't know maybe I'd make a good
bit
maybe I'd make a good bit listen to this
crazy sack of [__] let's listen
I told you my children don't worry about
the things that you see
because the things that you see are
temporary now you know you notice you
notice her Tempo I don't mean to stop it
so soon but a lot of that she says in
here is just [__] nonsense like it
didn't make any sense what she's saying
it's not I mean trust me when I say this
her message from God here is not [__]
Tethered to any kind of reality or facts
whatsoever
um at all
um but notice her Tempo and how she's
reading it right yeah VW Rock here on on
YouTube says
um she's reading
she's reading
but but more than she's reading it's
almost like she's reading I don't know
to a bunch of little kids
right like she's reading green eggs and
ham I do not like them Sam I Am I do not
like them I do not like green eggs and
ham right like she's reading a
children's book to a bunch of little
kids that's what it feels like you know
and you knew that when you're reading a
children's book you kind of have a Tempo
Dr Seuss had a Tempo
um to his books
I don't know I'm just pointing out some
obvious things here let's listen what
they are trying to do to your rightful
president that's a laughing matter
it is a laughing matter that you think
he's the rightful president that is
[__] hilarious
oh my God what the [__]
oh [__] that's no laughing matter you
see that you but you see what I'm
talking about with the tempo right okay
let's continue with this
I don't know what this is
there will be no indictment of my son
not the way they wanted it to go
so there's gonna be no indictment of his
son now again she's she's reading a
statement from God that has been given
to her I don't know if you're aware of
that she is reading a statement on her
computer that has been sent to her by
God and God is calling Donald Trump his
son which makes which makes Donald Trump
if you really do the math there the CRT
math if you do if you do the woke math
you're saying if Donald Trump is God's
son God's son was Jesus that makes
Donald Trump Jesus's brother
all right so his name is is Donald
Christ is that right am I getting that
right
am I am I getting that right is it
Donald is it Donald Christ
I don't know I'm just just trying to
make sense of this gibberish here
oh no no no the indictments
oh yes there will be indictments I
promise you
whoa whoa whoa even the crazy lady is
saying there's gonna be indictments did
you see that are you hearing this even
the crazy lady knows at least enough
reality to understand that Donald Trump
will be indicted you follow that Jazz
that she's got enough just enough
reality
to know that Donald Trump is going to be
indicted this is some wild [__] but it
will be indictments for those one the
ones excuse me
for the ones who are trying to make this
indictment
because this is a time of see time and
harvest
okay okay so she's that she's not saying
trouble being dated all right all right
all right okay okay I got it I get it I
get it she's not saying trouble being
indicted this is the hole we're going to
investigate the investigator [__]
that the people who are investigating
Donald Trump for his crimes and going to
prosecute and indict Donald Trump for
his crimes they're the ones going to be
indicted not Donald Trump being indicted
because they're Prosecuting his crimes
this is [__] ridiculous what how in
the [__] do they do such dumb stupid
mental gymnastics
how is it even possible
that they could even come up with this
garbage
Jesus [__] Christ literally and I
told you before many many times yeah in
many other words I have given to you
yeah they are Weeping a harvest okay
they have no idea what's coming oh the
storm I am an end to their plans because
I Am The Great I Am
she didn't seem so confident there at
the end I don't know if you caught that
I mean just trying to say but this Julie
green she's a prophet
she literally believes well her
supporters believe this she didn't
believe this probably she's a [__]
grifter right she literally believes
that this message that she's reading is
from God and that God is going to
somehow not let Donald Trump be indicted
and God is going to make sure that he
indicts the people who are investigating
Donald Trump for the indictment this is
wild [__] do you ever wonder why your uh
your Uncle Earl on Facebook or like your
your your crazy aunt or something like
that or your crazy cousin you know
Dwayne do you ever wonder why they're
[__] out there so far it's because of
these wackadas speaking of a wankadoo
[Music]
oh speaking of Wagner he's finally here
God damn everyone welcome back on video
Gabe Sanchez hey man it's been uh it's
been quite a trip oh yeah another trip
good a trip get a trip yeah
did you you're already reminding me of
the videos that uh Grandpa poopy pants
put out over the weekend I mean over the
last few days does it feel like a
[__] weekend
it feels like a Monday doesn't it we're
at Friday it's St Patrick's Day and I
feel like I'm at a [__] Monday this
is crazy man this is what a [__] [__]
show local
so did you have did you have muy loco
down there in Mexico City you told us
yesterday you're in Mexico City tell us
a little bit about uh what was what was
the best part and what was the worst
part let's start there yeah we want to
know uh well I mean I I don't know
that's what I'm asking okay all right uh
all right best part yeah I want to say
was
seeing my family all right
oh that's sweet that's sweet that's
sweet that's sweet well yeah how long
has it been since you've seen some of
them it's been it's been a while
so I went a year and a half ago right
right right and then before that it was
like 18 years oh wow God damn yeah so I
had so there's a much shorter period of
time between the last time and then yeah
yeah I I yeah and then I'll go back
probably in another six months or
something like that
um but
yeah it's uh well hang on I'm gonna tell
the audience this [__] was
sending me pictures of the street tacos
he was getting in Mexico City and I'm
like you son of a [__] like he's he's
bragging he's like hey look here's
because here's what happens on Taco
Tuesday because I've been trying to step
up my taco game week by week on Taco
Tuesday so as I step up my game I send
Gabe Sanchez the pictures of these the
the upgrades that I'm doing
give people an idea you you keep talking
I'll I'll get one ready to show people a
bit do you have to tell me to keep
talking because I mean that is just the
thing that [__] happens most of the
time I mean do I ever shut the hell up
no I mean even in private conversations
do I ever shut the hell up I mean
literally right now I'm dude I go to the
toilet I keep the I go on mute I walk
away I come back he's still talking oh
[__] he's [__] gay no he's sending me
pictures
um from
um uh Taco Stand I I don't remember
exactly where you're at you sent me uh I
was in yeah I was in Mexico City right I
was downtown
um toward
I was by El zocolo so it's like the Town
Square uh so down the street this is
actually one of the spots my dad is
my dad has this like crazy ability to
just like
uh walk in somewhere and then he just
like makes friends on the first time and
then he'll come back years later and
they'll be like oh my God and they'll
remember exactly who he is
so this one spot is actually featured if
everyone's watch the taco Chronicles
which is funny enough I also learned a
little family tidbit while I was home in
Mexico so Taco Chronicles is on Netflix
if you haven't seen it you should see it
one of the spots that we went to and we
went back to actually because I went
there last time uh is featured
in Taco Chronicles then at my uncle's
80th birthday I find out that his on his
wife's side of the family
he is related or she is related uh
uh to another person
who makes uh the Barbacoa Tacos on Taco
Chronicles like world famous Barbacoa
Taco I was like what the [__] are you
kidding me I'm just finding out about
this right now so
uh all these years all these years I was
like what what is going on here guys
what are you doing
uh so yeah they uh I guess I'm you know
tangentally related or connected to
uh
one of these people who make these
amazing Barbacoa tacos that have been
featured in here so
I've got uh I'm pulling up one of them
here I'll pull actually both of them but
uh anyway so put them in the overlay
yeah yeah okay yeah stick them in there
and I'll pull them up because you sent
me pictures uh because I think I I think
I I messaged you I'm like hey how's your
trip going or whatever and then you like
send me a picture of where you're
standing and he's standing in front of a
[__] Taco Stand like you son of a
[__] [__] I'm just asking how your trip
was going to say make me peanut butter
and jealous man yeah what the hell you
doing I mean well I had to give you an
idea of where I was right so he's
standing on the street he takes a
picture of the taco stand and then and
then um which I want you to describe
what it is uh if that is that one of the
pictures you're pulling up yeah I'm
gonna I'm putting them I'm putting them
both together and so so so why he does
that and then he sends me a picture of
the finished product which the taco
stand looks like you know your mouth is
watering if you get within 100 feet of
this thing right like you can't see this
thing and not be like I I just ate but I
want more to eat because I'm seeing this
thing but then he sends me the finished
product I'm like you [__] I mean what
am I gonna go to Taco Bell how the [__]
am I going to compete with this man
because it looked absolutely
um delicious but I'm I'm glad that you
got uh away for a while and you're able
to visit your family in Mexico City what
was the worst part while you're still
putting a what was the worst the worst
part is the fact that I I'm sick right
now oh like I had like I got a cold sick
yeah like I came back and it makes sense
I was traveling for like six days
non-stop throughout Mexico City down to
cornerback where my family is from then
back to Mexico City eating drinking low
sleep seeing people
partying all of that stuff and it was
just
I would say if there was a downside to
it it's it's that aspect which is
that I that I got sick but everything
else I was like uh people are asking in
the chat did you just ask for covid yes
yeah yeah okay good yeah I tested for
coven when I was at the airport and then
I tested again when we got back and then
my partner also tested so negative
um are you gonna put these pictures in
here so yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to I'm
trying to save it I'm trying to save it
oh okay then I'll give you the I'll give
you
the the chef the the man behind the
curtain and also the the finished
product yeah so so let me ask you so let
me ask you
and was it only Mexico City that you
went and visited or was there other
places that you went while you were down
here yeah so like I was in Mexico City
and then 45 minutes away is uh there's
in another state
of Mexico because Mexico obviously is
made up of States uh and there's a city
which is called cornevaca and that's
where my family lives I see and so I've
got you know there's like a a plot of
land so Corner how how close you said
it's like 45 minutes away
type area or is it like a no no no it's
like it's the capital of another state
of America okay I see so I see but it's
a yeah it's a city in other words yeah
yeah it's a city uh wow this is taking
forever to save
um it's
it's a very popular destination for
people to go who want to
um
like retire because the the weather
there it's it's the Eternal Spring right
so it's always beautiful weather it's
not too hot it's not too cold it's like
perfect spring weather someone's nice
honey someone's saying here is Mexico
City is huge
um that Mexico City is huge there are
like in it like as far as land mass one
of the largest cities in the world I
mean as far as like well I know there's
a population I know yeah the the
population I just looked this up the
other day because I was trying to figure
it out it's a
it is the
Mexico itself Mexico City is the let me
make sure I guess right Mexico City is
the eighth
largest
economy I think it is
it's huge
um
let me just make sure
now yesterday someone in Mexico yeah
Mexico City Mexico City is the eighth
largest economy
in the in the in the world right
um sorry uh what was what was the
question oh yesterday they were asking
um if you speak Spanish
yeah yeah I speak uh not as well as I
should but every time I go I'm still say
that why do you say not as well as you
should
because when I was a kid I spoke it and
then I got integrated in so you were you
were fluent
um yeah yeah so I was by bilingual as a
kid and then I got is that because your
dad was speaking in the house and you
had family members of the speakers yeah
I got you so so we would have my I
believe that would come into uh
to visit I had cousins who came into my
my you know my cousins my aunts my
uncles primas Primos they would all come
in to visit and then
um they would stay with us and then my
for the first few years my dad was
because my mom was working my dad would
pretty much stay with me and I would go
with him to work he would take me
everywhere to the market this and that
so he would always be speaking Spanish
so I spoke Spanish as a kid but then
when my dad got busy with work and when
I got you know integrated into the
American school system you know in
kindergarten first grade and second
grade and stuff like that my dad got
busy and then Spanish was not something
that was really spoken
uh at least in casual conversation you
know like when visit when family would
come and see me I would speak to them in
Spanish
and then they would practice their
English so it would be back and forth
but when I go back to Mexico it's kind
of like this because the best way to
learn another language is to be you know
in it right yeah in it and so whenever
you have to survive kind of thing yeah
yeah exactly and so going back uh a year
and a half ago two years ago when I went
back
that was that was great because I was
able to then like assimilate back in and
then like it was
uh it was like a wave because I had
spoken it for you know early on and then
like a little bit here and there and you
know but it wasn't like an everyday kind
of thing but then going back to Mexico
it was like everything came back you
know like as soon as you hear it and you
start speaking and then you're like oh
that's right that's that word okay cool
I gotta remember to come so it starts to
pull out those file cabinets right right
which is funny because um my my dad's
then is Polish and when he was a kid
they grew up in their house their
grandmother lived with them and she only
spoke polish she did not speak hardly a
word of English so
um they had to speak Polish in the house
when they were kids otherwise grandma
would get mad and she'd you know hit you
with a [__] cane or some [__] like it
was violent you know like well and
because she thought The Story Goes that
she thought the kids were speaking about
her if they were speaking in English you
know because yeah yeah you know they
deal with Trope right so
um my Grandpa would speak Polish a lot
now when my dad was a kid they'd go to
Chicago now my and because there's a big
Polish Community in Chicago and they go
to Chicago to visit
um my my Grandpa's brother and they
would sleep in the living room because
there's a little bitty tiny house that
him and his brothers are sleeping in the
living room and my grandpa and his
brother would be up in the in the
kitchen playing cards all night and you
couldn't understand a single word they
said besides curse words because they
were speaking in Polish to each other
now later on life before my grandpa
passed away before he went um to a
nursing home a few months before he
passed away
um it was Christmas time and we found a
uh a Christmas CD that was um Christmas
music but in Polish so they were all
singing Polish and he hadn't spoke
polish in years probably almost 35 years
is the last time he spoke polish and
then we gave him that Christmas album
just like what you're saying like when
you start to hear those words he's like
because he told us he's like you know I
haven't been able to think in Polish for
a long time but he's like now that I
I've been listening to this Christmas
music right now that that that language
just starting to come back to me to
where I can recognize the words and now
I can start to hear and translate it in
my mind so it's kind of um yeah it's
weird it's always with you I guess yeah
right they'd say riding a bike type
thing right yeah it really is and so
like going back
and it you know like you said it's kind
of like uh it is survival and so going
back and you know it's just myself or
myself and my partner going around and
walking around like they're you know
obviously like there's a lot of people
from all over the world speaking many
different languages obviously is the top
one for sure but you know I think it's
always best like if you go to another
country even if it's like as broken as
possible you're at least making the
effort because look the people who are
coming from another country into America
are hands down going to make
a hundred and ten fifty percent you know
150 percent
effort to learn how to speak English you
know and I think it's only right that
people who are visiting other country
even if it's the most broken right
obviously some people might be like more
like you know like [__] show your
nose at you or whatever right but
I do think there is something to be said
like if other people are coming to this
country in as shitty as the country can
be they're at least making an effort to
to meet us halfway or more than halfway
really and I think it's only right that
if we go to another country whether it
be France or I mean Iceland has the most
difficult one of the most difficult
languages uh to speak so if you can't
speak it makes total sense uh but if you
go to other countries like Spain or
Portugal or France or Germany like at
least the effort of like
trying to speak it or trying to say
something or like at least communicating
Bridging the Gap I think is is the least
we can do you know especially since like
uh second languages in this country I
feel like are so
like
second nature you know in the sense of
like there's like not even
not not even something that we consider
and and put within our education system
but uh the the I put the photo in there
okay let me show you in the audience
here's here's the pictures that Gabe
sent me from the from the sidewalk there
in Mexico City now if this doesn't make
you [__] hungry you're out of your
mind so for people who don't know this
is al pastor
and uh at the top which he didn't
because he just he had just run out but
at the top is uh Pina which is pineapple
and so then he you know [__] it's like
it's very delicate skinny shavings
of Alpa store in the taco and then he
this it's it really is an art of like
he like he slices off uh the pineapple
off the top and you'll see another Taco
stands if if they serve al pastor but
typically it's like with a huge knife
and like
they just cut it off the top and then
catch it and it was like and they'll
maybe cut a couple pieces or whatever
onions cilantro and that's it and then
you put on the salsa as needed as you
want right and of course the pineapple
goes on there yeah yeah so and and then
of course you had the beer there yeah
yeah so there's you know there's other
some uh there's other tacos that we were
having these just happen to be the two
that I got served first so wait sir you
carrying around this big mug of beer is
he serving beer in this uh no next to it
yeah they have beer and soda and okay
actually yeah I see I see I didn't yeah
I didn't see the picture the beer stand
I just got a picture of the taco
standing literally I messaged him and I
was like hey how's the trip going and he
says he's like here here's where I'm at
right now I'm like [__] you're trying
to make me hungry and here we are making
the audience hungry so this is this is
just one image um from the last that's
just one I want to oh I also went to
koyokan which is another part of Mexico
City or in Mexico and that's where Frida
Kahlo
uh her the blue house is right
um so went there I'd never been to her
house which is a museum now and so I was
able to kind of get it you know a
glimpse of
the
the artwork and the stuff that Cynthia
rice yeah everyone's uh yeah I'm look
it's I I'm hungry actually you know what
I'm I'm gonna we'll talk to you later
I'm just kidding
um no it's it's
it is so good it is so good I mean you
cannot I mean you can go wrong with
tacos obviously depending on where you
get them hey easy easy you know I said
him I sent him pictures of my tacos and
there's a there's a there's a sound on
Instagram it's white people taco night I
think is what it's called
why people taco night or something like
that and uh I think maybe you sent me
that video and this is the table yeah
right yeah it's just like ground beef
with right with seasoning on it Lettuce
cheese hard crunchy shells
um some tomato and um sour cream I think
yeah and um It's like white people taco
night and it's like yeah that's
you know it's not exactly on the street
in Mexico City right now here's what
I'll tell you of the audience
um and I really seriously want to do
this because when we were messaging back
and forth as he was at the Taco Stand
eating his tacos and drinking his beer I
said maybe maybe one of these days maybe
next year maybe sometime next time you
go you said about six months or a year
or something next time I'll have to go
down to Mexico City and we will air our
show live from Mexico City I think
that's a pretty damn good if we could
find like Mike because that's one what
was the problem with the wine bike
because you couldn't get away it was the
I was where I was staying the Wi-Fi
wasn't uh it wasn't strong like it's
just a spot that like it was like it was
okay but it wasn't strong enough to hold
like a video right we have to figure
that out yeah yeah and that's something
there are other hotels and other Airbnb
some kind of Studio or something maybe
has but the other nice thing I mean here
here's something else too is like
in Mexico City they offer you free Wi-Fi
so you can walk around oh whoa whoa what
kind of socialist garbage is that I'm
just saying I'm just saying if you if
you wanted to go around right uh that's
it is a benefit for sure of of walking
around Mexico City is like having a free
community Wi-Fi I mean it's enough it's
I'll say this it's enough to hold a
signal so like if you didn't have like
international calling or something like
that you know and you want to roam then
you could use that and you could walk
around and you know look up Google Maps
and you know get where you need to the
basics right but at least it's a it's a
service that's offered here in America
it's like Ah that's you don't get that
[__] you got to go to McDonald's or some
[__] right like literally like yeah
you would have to go internet you'd have
to go into someone's Lobby somewhere and
then they'd be like what are you doing
here and you'd be like I just need the
Wi-Fi right which you know is an
accomplishment that Democrats have made
in this country they actually provided
uh money for infrastructure for Rural
Wi-Fi which and in this country the
rural areas are where Wi-Fi doesn't
exist and internet uh high-speed
internet doesn't exist right speaking of
high speed we really got to kick it in
gear here and get to the bonehead of the
weeks so everyone stick around we'll be
right back with bonehead of the week
right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
couldn't resist playing the uh Babble
I'm just talking about a person saying
languages
I thought it breaks pretty well in there
yeah it's pretty pretty crucial to get
around this country
welcome back
and it's Friday we're in the second half
you know what that means
[Music]
bonehead of the weekend there's no
surprise today there really is I mean
good God
I we we were trying to figure out who
the bonehead is going to be Ben Stein
made a video last night he was trending
I think we almost made a mistake putting
him on I mean it's a real bone-ended
thing that he did but there's there's
plenty boneheads this morning that are
happening um and I threw I threw one in
last minute
what oh on the um the alpha gut is there
anything nope oh the DM oh I see that
now yeah I see that now that was a that
was a okay so you kind of just boom put
that in there okay well because our
Alpha [__] was in consideration for uh
bonehead and I really think she should
have been on the pole yeah
um because the problem is that people
don't know her name
what do you mean like people don't know
her name well enough
you know the best the best part about
this is because
um we showed this video earlier on in
the week and this is like two or three
days ago right yeah and so
and I'm not I don't want to give it away
yet but she she can't describe the word
what woke means like what what it means
to her like and you probably know what
I'm already talking about but this
morning all over the internet all over
Twitter
um people are discovering like old
tweets that she wrote and what's funny
is you go oh I screenshotted all of them
well yeah you got to yeah she might
delete them but here's the thing on the
show the other day when I went through
this that video of her not being able to
describe Luke and maybe I should say
this for the bonus banana [__] it
um
I I call her a [__] racist I didn't
know who she was I had no [__] clue I
said she's a [__] racist and I
described why I gave my reasoning why I
thought that I mean I just didn't you
racist like I gave the whole you know
yeah yeah explanation of why she said
why you are on the racist right that
right that's it that's it you know
what's funny is is I brought that up
about the hard art and uh our little are
you're you're you're uh he's in love
with you Dustin Taylor on Facebook
Justin Taylor is he here today oh my God
he's in here he must have been here
today yeah I think so I think he wants
to make like a Michael Knowles type
short film with you even sort of look
man I don't know if we give financing I
I will be acting I don't know if he will
why you know I I said this earlier about
the Michael Knowles
um short film The Lighting shitty the
camera angles are horrible the [__]
audience the the dot the dialogue is
even worse than that the delivery
delivery is one of the the worst Parts
but I will say it's just acting it's
just acting Michael I don't know if
you're actually a gay man that has sex
with other men but it's just acting and
you're just pretending possibly in the
things so stop trying to stop other
people oh don't worry I I have the
original I have the original uh saved
and I have dude I went in I wanna I went
into a deep because like you were
sending me [__] you were sending me [__]
I'm like oh there's a what was it it's
coming yeah there was definitely what
was that coming uh because
I knew it's coming it's coming it's
coming it's coming it's coming I knew I
knew he was a failed actor right I had
seen some stuff but then last night I
was like um
is it even actually porn I don't know
but now I wonder if I should upload
these to PornHub
hey we've got our PornHub account
let's do it let's I've got dude there
are I've got scenes of him I've been
trying to figure out how the hell we're
gonna get on PornHub maybe that's the
way we do it is we upload Michael
Knowles videos to Pornhub Michael knows
yeah we'll see if he'll is it softcore
I mean it's well there's that scene yeah
which is funny because of how that's
there's more scenes of him having sex
with dudes there's there's more there's
more of what leads into that scene in
the sense of like they're outside the
building kind of thing and then he comes
in because the awkwardness in the scene
I wasn't sure if it was the editing be
that way or if it was just he actually
made the other actor feel uncomfortable
what I'll say is this the
the camera angles the lighting the sound
as we've as we mentioned are are awful
everyone like this is a student film so
I get it right we're limited on research
but also
there are certain creative
creative choices that are made in here
where I'm like uh that's a cheap kind of
there's a way that you could have done
it better right and it a lot of it is
it's them having to avoid the aspect of
it two dudes kissing which is oh my God
it's so weird two dudes kissing get the
[__] over man if you went to school and
you're an actor
there is going to be maybe a time when
you might have to kiss a man God forbid
even if you're a heterosexual even if
you're a straight dude and you're like
whatever it's acting acting acting and
made for Michael Knowles he's like oh no
we're getting too close to the fire here
I don't want something to erupt and he
doesn't want that
that that inside that in my desire to
come out and say oh my God maybe maybe I
have feelings for another man hmm but
the way in which they film this because
there's more and I think I'm actually
I'll do maybe do this on Sunday I'll I'm
gonna I think Sunday I'm gonna do a deep
dive
into uh Michael Knowles's
resume of film for everyone to watch
because it is something it is good it's
well good I I will if if you want to
I'll find a way we will post that [__]
on you on our YouTube channel I mean a
PornHub Channel speaking of YouTube real
quick um someone I I think it's MJ
saying that um it looks like YouTube has
reinstated Donald Trump here's the um
here's YouTube Insider
um I don't mean to jump in with breaking
news here before we get to bonehead
starting today Donald J Trump channel is
no longer restricted and can upload new
content we carefully evaluated
the continued risk
of worldwide violence
while balancing the chance for voters to
hear
equally for major national candidates in
the run-up to the election now this
again folks this is what I've been
telling you he's going to be the nominee
yeah he's gonna be the nominee now this
is coming from you YouTube Insider this
is this is um one of YouTube's verified
accounts
um if I can get it
here I'll just go to it yeah it's an
official page it is a verified account
um it's there for their updates in their
press so this is in a uh quote official
press release from YouTube Insider on
Twitter
um so there there it is and it follows
up it says
um here's the follow-up to it now this
channel will continue to be subject to
our policy just like any other channel
so in other words they're saying we're
reinstating him but hey you [__] around
you'll find out right we'll suspend you
which we we just came off a suspension
uh seven day suspension for some [__]
that I said I don't know they don't
really tell you what they don't I I tell
you they don't tell you what you say
specifically they're not like you can't
say this that you said in that episode
they're like hey in that two hours you
said a lot of [__] Tony I'm like yeah
got it every [__] day and they're
like there's something in that two hours
that you said that we don't like we
won't tell you what it is you got to go
figure it out so I don't I don't know
what the hell it is I have no idea and
but here's the thing is you can listen
to all the Band episodes because there's
several of them
there's several of them they pulled down
that's just one of them yeah that's just
the one I got suspended for
I don't know there's probably six
episodes that are missing from YouTube
because they don't like what I said in
that two hours that I said it but
they're all on Apple Spotify and Google
so go go to your favorite directory and
download it and if you find the banned
episodes let me know if there's
something in there that you think I
should have been banned on YouTube for
maybe I'll let YouTube Insider know that
hey hey [__] how about starting
today you don't don't jack with my
channel how about that how's about that
but apparently Donald Trump's um YouTube
channel is now now going to be able to
upload content so what do you what do
you think that means what do you think
that means game Sanchez do you think do
you think that means that these
[__] basement videos that he's making
are gonna end up being shown on YouTube
instead of Rumble I I both probably both
I mean what we well what we know is that
his uh his social media network uh truth
social
is probably gonna
Crash and Burn real soon right what so
explain that to the audience because
we'll get the bone in and that's
important here now that we have this
breaking news because there's a lot of
news going on right now in in Paris and
France and
um and I'd like to talk about that but
we really ain't got time today but um
but tell them about the why fraud social
is in such trouble so it's like that
fact's not going to work out right yeah
yeah uh so the spec is not gonna work I
mean look everything is under
investigation now right so the digital
world acquisition Corp for the the D
whack
um so there was this back right which is
there was supposed to be a merger uh
between Digital World acquisition Corp
and the Trump media right which is where
which was gonna that was what's gonna
make Trump media public right exactly
and so there well not only because they
were seeking about a billion dollars in
financing through this right right and
if you look at the price of dwac the
digital world acquisition Corp right the
high was like 100 and keep in mind I
laugh I laugh because Margaret Taylor
green lost I don't know [__] some
five digits worth of you know like fifty
thousand dollars some [__] like that
which is great to me happy but she
bought into it and then I want to say
maybe around February or March of last
year so in one year's time okay one
year's time
it went from
uh it was the high of a hundred
and it all the way down to twelve
dollars so it's lost 88 dollars in value
in one year
so if this company doesn't have the
money right in the in the market to say
hey it's worth to have the backing of
whatever billions of dollars one billion
or whatever it is to merge these
companies together
and then in addition to that there was
what eight million dollars of shady
money that was tied to a Caribbean
account from yeah and possibly had
Russian money in it and people were like
even people at the company like oh
that's a little weird right and then
find out there's a federal investigation
the sdny which is even worse right when
you're talking about crime uh being
investigated before this even this SPAC
even comes uh to be uh an actual
acquisition to become public right and
then you've got also uh you know another
CTO leaving the company right so this
this company from the very beginning
was
we knew it right everybody has Trump's
name on it it's [__] going come on
it's great well how long before because
it didn't take much more than a year to
find out that there was a criminal
investigation into this Trump media how
long before we have
um a fifth uh probe into Trump and his
crimes with the Trump trading cards the
nft [__] how long you think I mean
sometimes this fall we're probably gonna
have we're probably gonna be like hey
hey guess what another Trump business
has a criminal probe wouldn't you know
it I mean it's one of those things you
it's it's not it's not if right it's
when and I think whenever these things
have whenever Trump opens a new business
or a new venture or whatever it is
there's always the question of like all
right well at this point it's bound to
go bad uh how long we talking we got a
year a two year Runway before really
like the [__] hits the fan for him right
well just know enough you know we know
in Trump news the Trump attorneys are
not having a a good go about and one of
them ended up on the bonus of the week
so let's get to the Bone end of the week
you already know who wins [__]
undefeated it's [__] ridiculous you
people out there I I have a sense Gabe
Sanchez that the audience made sure made
sure to fix and rig this bonehead of the
week but we'll see everyone let's get to
bonehead of the week foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
head of the week welcome to this edition
of bonehead of the week
it's not surprising what happened I
think the audience rigged this one we
had Ben Stein which I'm kind of
disappointed we put him on this because
of our Alpha cook this week but we you
know we'll manage to uh knock them both
down here yeah yeah and then
representing Marjorie Taylor hoof foot
Petty Yeti green and Joe Taco how do you
say his last name
I don't know I mean like I look at that
taco guy gives a bad name for tacos it
is it's kind of weird it hurts me inside
to know that his name has Taco in it
especially since we were talking so much
about time it's earlier it's just
ridiculous what is this Taco Friday it's
Saint Patrick's Day in it's Taco Friday
[__] it's a weird timeline we live in
World we're just living in it yeah a lot
of people in the comments yeah Taco
penis oh Taco penis
ouch Deco penis seems to be a taco penis
all right well I'm not saying it right
other people are right many people a lot
of people are saying many people are
saying they're saying Taco penis
pronounced Taco penis so today we just
may make sure that uh Joe is Taco penis
but let's start with Ben Stein this one
isn't going to take long at all did he
really did he did would someone
recording him in a nursing home or did
he actually record this to post this on
the [__] internet I don't I don't
know who is uh who is watching him right
he was like taking care of him right now
but whoever it is
I just
I mean at one point it was the [__]
Aunt Jemima Syrup thing and Donald Trump
there oh my God man and now this new one
this what but I mean number one here I
put him on the screen it's fuzzy here
not because I have it pause but it's
like they're using the high eight
[__] camcorder oh yeah and then they
convert it over to digital it's weird
it's either that or they at like
vaseline on the lens or some [__] this
is like a carry Lake I was yeah Carrie
Lake filter
without making sure that he's focused
right I don't know what he's dressing up
for too right like no one is no one is
oh this guy sleeps in this these clothes
are you kidding me this is better as a
tie yeah sure this mother this is his
pajamas man just like Steve Bannon
sleeps in a polo underneath a black
shirt right underneath a black blazer
with those three pens that are in the in
the
right no Ben's not this is he's in his
pajamas here I can't confirm that it's
just it's just a single piece of
clothing it's like a snuggie it's got a
zipper in the back yeah
okay so what it's not gonna take long
for us to Plate now this is like a
minute and 12 seconds but he just
Grandpa here just Rambles on and on and
drools into his own words here but
listen to the very first part this is
[__] wild [__] that he he was like
yeah this is great this is me making
great points and I should post this on
the internet let's watch
[Music]
I would drive by the neighborhoods
and it's hard to hear because um
they don't know how to record video now
I don't know if you know and the
audience knows this but Ben Stein is not
only a personality that talks about
money and finances but this guy was an
actor not like Michael Knowles a failed
actor this guy was actually an actor do
you do you know one of the most famous
movies he's in yeah of course which is
it that's it that's it yeah so he plays
the dealer Bueller Mueller Bueller my
cousin's sister's boyfriend's brother
like the whole thing said he was at a
Baskin Robbins and he fainted what
that's when he's asking for oh yeah yeah
the girl was like oh I heard right yeah
yeah okay now I got you uh you're saying
[Laughter]
I don't know we're talking about pajamas
yeah [__] okay so he's talking about how
his family
um his mom and dad would drive him into
Baltimore okay now if you're not aware
Baltimore is very close to Washington DC
DC almost the exact same you know City
in essence there's kind of invisible
lines but it's of the same metropolitan
area right
the difference is is that Baltimore is
notoriously has a higher black
population of black folks and that is
what he's getting at here listen
predominantly almost all black people
and they look so raggedy
oh my God so I don't know if you caught
that audience but he says he says the
truth which is that Baltimore is
predominantly black
and then he says they looked
raggedy raggedy like the [__] do you
remember do you remember the Don Imus
moment
oh that was a nappy hair one yep yeah
yeah it destroyed him it destroyed him
we are now in a timeline where we're
like Grandpa who's recording you why are
they recording you and why are they
posting this [__] on the internet right
like we're we're just so far away from
what is
um acceptable because it's social media
and it feels like
I mean it really does feel like a
hostage video
but it at the end and I actually think
that the person holding the camera is
the hostage right like I'm like yeah the
person the person that's there that is
recording for sure does not want to be
there one bit no absolutely uh and yeah
for people who can't hear it the audio
obviously is yeah that's [__] it's a
[__] but just know that Ben Stein is a
racist
oh racist so here's the heart are there
racist the the the here's the thing it's
what he says in the audio if you want a
synopsis is that his parents when he was
a child used to drive him into Baltimore
which is predominantly black and those
black people in Baltimore look so
raggedy that's that's what he says now
he continues on in this video about how
great how great it's been and how great
the country is now to people of color
and he literally says in the video he
says colored people yeah I'm not saying
that he says it single take unedited
he's like right it's a rap right let's
go print ship it put it on the internet
and he trends
for about 10 minutes until I want to
know I want to know where he originally
posted that I don't know uh Ron uh
philipkowski is the one who found it
right so I have no idea I have no idea
some some deep Cesspool probably on
parlor or [__] and some some
tree dish somewhere on the internet you
know where they gestapo gazpacho Police
Hangout
and uh you know all those that a
beautiful place on the internet I'm sure
what's great originally posted it what's
crazy is Ben Stein had to have known
what Scott Adams did I don't know if you
guys know who Scott Adams is he's the
the Cartoonist the of the cartoon
Dilbert uh because Scott Adams basically
said the same thing other although in
better audience kind of sense oh yeah
better audio better camera
um and it looked like he was recording
himself not a hostage was recording him
but but Scott Adams said you need to
move to a wide area move away from black
people right and you know you just you
gotta Wonder like these people like Ben
Stein and and Adams and stuff like look
you guys have money you guys just shut
the [__] up man you have money why do
you have a podcast right why are you why
are you bringing out these views right
you could say it
if you here's the thing
these people complain they [__] and
moan they say oh you can't say this
stuff because people are going to cancel
then don't say it then don't say it if
you know the consequence of what you're
gonna say
is somebody saying oh you know what
we're gonna remove your cartoon or
you're not employed or you can't come
here anymore you've been 86 right if
it's any of those things
then it's almost like you know what's
gonna happen you know the repercussions
of how people are going to react
then don't say it then don't just say it
say it look in the mirror definitely
don't record it in the mirror yeah just
like don't record it just look in the
mirror pretend like you're gonna record
it right straight into the mirror and
say the things that you really want to
say
and then put the phone down and say man
glad I didn't record that and I'm glad I
didn't post it to the internet right
because the internet is forever yeah
well um Scott Adams Ben Stein and
Michael Knowles are finding that out
um so is our Alpha cuck of the week but
we got it we gotta get to
Joe Taco penis here
um he went in RB Melbourne show
um and we we went over this video the
other day and I said this is my
description of it and I think it's a
pretty good description of this is Joe
Taco penis tried to grab Ari melber
by the receipts okay so in this exchange
because I'm going to show you this here
because I'm just going to show you this
once and a short clip of it if you want
to go watch the whole clip go watch how
he he's I think it's like 20 20 minutes
long yeah but he but he says Trump's not
a liar and then he said yeah well it's
not the truth and it's just boneheaded
[__] yeah but but this is my lead in to
show you the Trump videos because that's
what I really want to show you yeah
because he's truly a bonehead here that
Joe Taco penis is kind of a bonehead for
representing him unless he's already got
his money which I doubt he has and then
Daddy will
um but here is the moment
where Joe Taco penis grabs Ari melber by
the receipts okay here's the moment
here's the moment pay attention that's
not a lie here's why it's not like could
you did you know about this
did you know about this no I don't but
we don't need that that
don't
don't don't read that paper don't don't
don't you dare read that paper okay
because if you read that paper it's
gonna say that Trump is bad
and it's really going to bang up my case
in court now he goes on Joe Taco penis
goes on to talk about how the reason why
trump-wide or excuse me didn't tell the
truth you know because there's a
difference there is totally a difference
between lying and then not telling the
truth alternative or alternative facts
maybe right again
now he goes on to say that the reason
why Trump isn't lying is because he
can't break the confidentiality
agreement that he had with Stormy
Daniels the problem is
the problem that he's going to have with
that argument in court he was trying to
make that case to Ari right that that's
why this isn't crime which the actual
confidentiality agreement has no bearing
in this case because of the crime that
it's used to cover up just like um right
now Jack Smith is seeking uh to talk to
Donald Trump's attorneys about the
obstruction in the documents case yeah
um and using using the the the crime
fraud exception you sent me something
here yeah so this is a recent
development from this morning so this in
this case or uh in well no in a case
well I don't know if it's from this case
but it's from a document
um from 2018. okay so this is Ryan
Goodman is reporting this Trump attorney
Joe Taco penis I think that's how we say
it
um
has had an attorney-client relationship
with stormy Daniel what the actual [__]
um
under ABA New York State ethics rules
difficult to see how he can represent
Trump calls Daniel's uh claim of a fair
untrue calls her an extortionist so
there's a conflict of interest right
knowing that he at one point
so this is his words in
2018. okay so is this is who lemon here
is this Don Lemon is he's uh I don't
know if that's Don Lemon stormy
approached you about your representation
here's the question did you get any
impression that she may have signed NDA
under duress
and was she afraid for her physical
safety which is a legitimate question
under the confidentiality agreement and
the check
now Taco penis is quote again I think
that's his name that's what the chant
says how you pronounce it yeah yeah this
is sorry this is the exchange from CNN
yeah Don Lemon there's a video of this
uh no no but if you go further in I mean
there there might be uh okay there might
be a clip someone out there okay so if
you go down in in the thread he says the
more about it okay so so talk Joe Taco
penis I'm just saying Taco penis because
that's the audience the chat the people
are saying that's how you pronounce it
so I want to be careful you know me I
want to get all the names right every
last one of them pronounced correctly
Taco penis says yes of course and I
can't really talk about my Impressions
or any conversations we've had because
there is an attorney client privilege
that attached even to a
consultation so he in this questioning
he's representing do you think Donald
Trump did this on purpose
do you think Donald Trump talked Joe
Taco penis into breaking these ethics so
that way he can go on Ari melber and try
to try to float him out there as the
attorney because he was supposed to be
the quote good attorney this is a good
attorney and Joe Taco penis is not but
he also didn't I if I remember correctly
I don't know if he still did or at one
point I'm pretty sure he at one point
represented one of the people that maced
the capital police
may have he also represented Kimberly
Guilfoyle I believe in her testimony to
the January 6 select committee oh
because he said that on Ari's interview
that he represented Kimberly Guilfoyle
right right um now I don't know if it's
the
I'd have to go back and re-watch and
really find that out but I feel like I
feel like um it was either the select
committee her testimony to them or the
testimony to possibly the grand jury
that that doesn't mean in Washington
because the thing is if people people
don't know this so like when you if you
go for a consultation
and this is also what people do there's
a strategy it's it's shitty that people
do this but this is how it works
uh
uh the way that it works is if I go out
like I have a case against someone like
some people will do this in their in
their divorce uh when when they're
seeking representation they'll go and
they'll get a consultation from every
major lawyer out that's available
because what happens is I get a
geographical area that way the person
has to go outside that area to find out
or they can't find someone that is as
good as people right right so now you
put them at a disadvantage because now
they've they've had a prospective
meeting to say hey I'm looking to get a
divorce and I wanted to chat with you
and basically it could be a super simple
conversation but enough to give them
context about what's going on as soon as
they have that meeting that means that
that lawyer that representation legal
counsel is not available for the other
party in this case whether it be divorce
or or whatever right and so right and
the reason why is because there's a
conflict of interest and the conflict of
interest is that they know about the
case already the other sides uh case
that is being made so
um here is now he's gonna need Good
attorneys Donald Trump that is
he may not have access to them all the
Good attorneys are like look dude yeah
he represented the guy the guy with the
beanie if you look at the photo but yeah
he represented the guy who maced Brian
signic I see okay so just goes to show
you exactly who Joe Talking Joe Taco
penises so here is um I want to show you
this video this speaking of January 6
defendants dude seems really scared that
Jack Smith is going to prosecute him for
January 6 and put him in prison for
January yeah he's really terrified of
this listen to this [__] just this 16
seconds of this um shitty diaper rant
here and how he describes January 6
defendants because he's gonna he's gonna
be one he's gonna be one yeah listen to
this patriotic Americans are being
prosecuted for peacefully protesting a
stolen election let them go
they were convicted or are awaiting
trial based on a giant lie yeah no [__]
no [__] no [__] [__] sandwich oh my God
he's so serious it I feel like somebody
somebody out there because I don't have
the time to do it
uh well maybe I will
put
put the line of him let my people go and
put it to the Disney film
uh I think it's Disney which is uh about
Moses right and he's like Let My People
Go you know like just just a clip again
and again and again just for that song
I'm sure it'll match up perfectly
uh uh well he's losing his mind he's
losing his [__] mind and he's there's
a lot of clips of because there's one
clip of him out there basically saying
uh America is the enemy and Russia is
our Russia is who we need to protect he
literally is saying Putin is a good guy
Russia is a good guy America is the
enemy like he's saying that [__] like
what the [__] and you people say we hate
our country you you [__] you
trait treasonous pieces of [__] what the
[__] is wrong with you but here is his
statement
um wait hold on hold on got a correction
thank you it's not Disney it's
DreamWorks I just verify that and yeah
anyway it was The Prince of Egypt
by Dreamworks I got you well here is
doesn't Disney own DreamWorks now that
doesn't Disney own everything though
they own everything I don't know if they
own that I don't think they own
DreamWorks man I don't know who the [__]
who knows they'll own it soon
um here is um here's Grandpa's statement
here this is wild [__] this is wild [__]
here
now after reading this statement
yesterday this is real this is this is
[__] real this is not something you
made you know
there was one going around the other day
what was the one going around the other
day it was it was attacking one yeah it
was it was a fake one that was attacking
everyone including uh Cohen and Rudy
Giuliani yeah hi everybody Ron meatball
run and and when I saw it you could tell
it was a fake but I mean
it's hard to tell did Seth Abramson get
a little bit I don't know if he you know
the last time we had this problem were
um
you may or may not have um made up a
statement from Mar-A-Lago like we're
gonna see here on the screen and we put
meatball Ron in it remember that that
was was that a [__] year ago that was
a year ago man yeah it was uh it was a
year ago
and we put meatball Ron in it
and we made Trump go after him and
everyone's like oh this is so fake you
can tell it's fake because he's going
after Ron desantos and I'm like here we
are a year later and the [__]
calling him a pedophile on true social
I'm like come on come on we we are in
the prediction business here at the Tony
Michaels podcast but here's the thing is
it is so difficult not not just for you
but just about anyone to make a fake
statement now
it's it's so [__] difficult and the
reason why is there's so many big
accounts out there watching every single
[__] time he posts because he says
wild and crazy [__] and folks I know I
know a lot of people are going to be
pissed off when I say this and they're
going to disagree with me listen
it's gonna be a [__] Dandy when he
gets back on YouTube it's gonna be a
Dandy when he gets back on Twitter and
when he gets back on Facebook because
true social is all but done like you
said earlier so he's getting back on
Twitter soon he's gonna have to and it's
oh it's gonna be just the cream of the
crop of chaos what do you got here is
this um so click the click the one
that's the last one because the other
one was someone else but click mine okay
this is this is yours this is the
original which by the way now it has a
community note on it does it really yeah
oh this is great so here's what happened
we hatched a plan uh because David made
several these fake ones and I don't
remember what the situation was really
but I'm like hey we should make a fake
statement so you wrote it and um and
then you sent it to me I'm like ah we
need to we need to put a few more
capitalizations in it and we need to
make it look more like Trump I think
um but you said Trump doesn't seem happy
with Joe Rogan right now that's what it
was yeah it was a podcast yeah I don't
want him on there yeah [__] that guy I'm
not gonna have him on I'm not gonna
platform it
um so I was like hey this is a perfect
time to make a statement you should do
one of these fake statements so Gabe
made this one up
um this is a Gabe Sanchez
um uh nft we you should sell this as an
internet yeah
um it says uh statement by Donald J
Trump 45th president of the United
States and it's just it looks just like
it would if it was screenshot off of
true social because you made several of
these before but it was before true
social existed yeah yeah and I said no
no we got to make it look like a true
social post right so here is this July
5th so not quite a year ago we're
getting there almost we're getting there
uh Donald Trump apparently said hearing
that lying Joe Rogan doesn't want me on
his podcast which that was the truth uh
he said he was asked more than once to
have me on that seems like the truth he
did say that Joe Rogan did say that lies
um obviously that would be what he would
say
um he asked me many times but I said no
no it really should have been camping
yeah yeah yeah we [__] that maybe an
exclamation point we we missed that one
I know we missed that one uh he would be
lucky to have America's greatest
president as a guest this so sounds like
him it would be a record setting and A
smart business move for Spotify here's
where the desantos part comes in Lion
Joe which is Joe Rogan would rather have
a second-rate president guess like
gutless Ron DeSantis on his low rated
show again we called him gutless all the
way back we had
Donald Trump calling
Rhonda Santos
gutless Ron back on July 5th do you
think we could get him goat him into
into adopting this nickname gutless Ron
it's possible meatball meatball's not
far from gut yeah yeah yeah I mean like
how sweet would that be gutless Rhonda
santis we know that he eats uh chocolate
pudding with two fingers three fingers
yes
well I mean I guess it probably depends
on the pudding cup yeah right if it's in
a bowl or is it in a pudding cup because
you know he's got fat meatball fingers
sure yeah yeah so he's like I could only
fit so many oh he dipped two fingers in
this [__] cake I feel like it's also
in um you've seen you've seen um there
it is there's the warning there boom
yeah
this is the one that Seth aberson got
his undies in a bundle he got so pissed
he did like a four hour Instagram live
on this I went and watched about I don't
know 10 minutes of it and he's such a
[__] pussy-ass [__] I couldn't take
any more of him like you're lying
through your teeth Seth he's like I know
comedy and I know Santa and I know I'm a
professor this is it really it's all
because he got super butt hurt because
one he didn't fact check it and shared
it and it was like oh my god look
they're fighting he retweeted it
immediately now what's funny about this
is he was like this is really bad for
democracy and what you're doing is
you're you're raising Ron desantis's
platform and you're gonna make him the
president of the United like he blamed
you for destroying democracy or some
[__] of course he said he said Gabe
Sanchez is the greatest one of the
greatest threats to democracy which I
gotta tell you it's a [__]
that is amazing because all I did was
share this and then he freaked out about
it oh my God
Seth Everson Hey listen if there's any
Seth simps that are in the audience if
there's any of them out there please
please give him our best regards for
being such a [__] ass [__] and why do
you follow this guy why do you take him
seriously he's not a serious person I
mean
you're still reading after his
387th uh thread tweet uh he's supposed
to be a journalist and a reporter and he
didn't have he didn't take enough time
he didn't even go to your profile to see
that you've been fact checked by Daniel
Dale on these very things like it said
all the time that's one of the things
that pissed him off right yeah and I
said fact checked by uh Snopes Daniel
Dale CNN and also Reuters and the reason
he got so pissed off and he was like oh
look he's bragging about it and here's
the thing I was I was not it was not
even in
because here's thing at the time at the
time that that one went viral
he saw the comment in the comment that I
had in my bio of like being fact-checked
was from a previous tweet about uh
um it was about a a previous one that
was made of I think it was about
Mike Pence right and that's yeah yeah
that that's the one that Daniel Dale uh
right I think he bought and then he put
a big X there yeah and that's what that
wasn't connects to so because Daniel
Dale was your arch enemy for a long time
right on these fake statements right up
until this point where Seth Abramson
stepped in it and and he basically
called you the greatest threat in
democracy the four-hour Instagram lime
on how you were and he was like this is
gonna oh blah blah blah but I wanna I
wanna give you an idea of how much
insight
how much Insight um our audience says uh
Margie said here this is this is these
are all dated July 5th 2022. she said
those two deserve each other oh my God
I mean this is listen we we had no idea
that that Donald Trump would be calling
Ronda Santos in less than a year from
this fake statement that he would be
calling him a pedophile on true social
uh Megan here says um they're starting
to eat their own
and then uh someone here calls it this
is fake you know who that is a Breitbart
right yeah yeah she's a bright so of all
people to say that this is fake the
[__] journalist in quotes I use that
journalist right from Breitbart I wonder
I wonder if I wonder if she's doing any
reporting
um on uh on uh
on desantos and Trump's little little
Feud right now I wonder if she's doing
any reporting on that uh probably that's
a good question about CNN yeah okay no
you know what she's doing she's saying
she's talking about the violence that UC
Davis when turning points oh my goodness
influence on campus they broke a window
oh my God the son the people holding a
sign those those those scary those scary
and masculine uh uh libtards they kicked
a window oh yeah those
um uh Tara said Breitbart is faker
these are so funny even a year later oh
here Tina says oh Ronnie them are
fighting words
like we call this Wu-Tang for children
says this is real this is or is this
this is real because it's hilarious uh
yeah it's sure it's real it's real now
it's real now it wasn't real then but
it's [__] real now man this meme is
uh I a fake post what yeah I don't know
probably saying this this is a fake post
this is a fake post okay
um I'm just this is this is great
um uh Betty Bowers says I'm more
delighted
with more significant fireworks than
Donald Trump calling runs and gutless
pretend so
I mean again this was fake at the time
it's not so fake now yeah um someone
says here June Moon liberal says he's
gone over the edge
I read that as he's gone over the fridge
but you know that works too did you
really well when I when I read he's gone
over the edge I just read him I in my
mind I said he's gone over the fridge oh
okay well that happens that happens oh
my god well yeah okay so everyone go
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna go retweet this
again
um
and see if people can catch I'm going to
retweet this so that you guys can find
it
BW Rock Gabe is an arsonist lights the
fire and walks away laughing yeah it's
true it worked it worked you know a lot
of people doubt that that we have a
power here because we've said that Liz
Harrington is listening uh to our videos
she's she's always every day two hours
yeah
I believe that fox producers are also
um listening to the show they're like
this is this is this is where
um the the the the national Narrative of
the left is coming from this is the
messaging that they're gonna have if
they're worth this [__] so um they come
here to watch okay we gotta move on I I
want to keep going with the fake Donald
Trump and and bashing the bonehead Seth
Abramson but we got to move on to our
other moments okay so what why did this
DM ring in what happened here Vladimir
Putin oh my God to find this face today
or is this the face he's had no no
that's that's one that I that's our God
in the back pocket for quite some time
did you have to make this for bone and
or has he been around no he's been on
bonus okay it's been a while now though
yeah uh it probably was last year when
he originally invaded Ukraine yeah
that's probably what it was so what what
did he what did he do to deserve the
dishonorable mention this morning right
so what happened this was a you are
called an audible on this correct right
right so it's the international criminal
court right so where
um
where uh Jack Smith Jack Smith you mean
you mean where he prosecutes war
criminals yeah well previously because
he had to leave well right now he's now
he's now he's coming after another war
criminal right uh treasonous piece of
[__] yeah I get it uh so the
international criminal court has
announced today that it has issued an
arrest warrant for Vladimir Putin on
suspicion of war and suspicion [__]
it's not suspicious he literally
broadcasted out everyone's documented of
war crimes because of involvement in
abductions of children from Ukraine
so that's the that's the latest
um that piece of [__] well
um I don't know if you've seen but uh
Marjorie Taylor green has been simping
for
um
pretty hard very difficult time knowing
her geography I'll tell you that much
also yeah well also um Rhonda santis
speaking around to Santa's and Donald
Trump Donald Trump made a great video
from his basement Liz Harrington
um again you're you're falling back on
some of our suggestions they made the
lighting is too dark it's too much
makeup yeah and the angle sucks you
really well the darker it is the makeup
it covers up the wrinkles of his leather
face yeah but you can do other things in
post to do that yeah you could do
something well that's like that one
video he had they put a big circle
around they highlighted uh an area of
his face and then lit it up but when you
looked at it you could I was like oh
look you could see there's like a halo
around his face because what they did
was
for whatever reason instead of
brightening the whole image the video
they decided to say you know what we're
just going to put a circle here
that you can they did that post yeah
yeah yeah I mean they're changing the
lighting post here's the here's the uh
the New York Times breaking the news uh
the international criminal court issuing
and arrest warrant for Vladimir Putin of
Russia for war crimes
um the court has said that Putin board
and visual criminal responsibility for
the abduction and deportation of a
Ukrainian children uh oh he's you know
what yo what's funny is uh Donald Trump
and Marjorie Taylor green all the Q and
honors they're supposed to be what's
that save the children thing aren't they
supposed to be against um yep what's
that word it starts with the T God damn
it I can't man trafficking maybe is that
what it is trafficking children yeah
it seems um seems like projection maybe
always every [__] time with these
[__] okay so he's got the
dishonorable mention uh we know Vladimir
Putin has been committing several war
crimes but apparently uh uh arrest
warrant from the international criminal
court has um been issued for abduction
and deportation of Ukrainian children
Vladimir Putin is a child trafficker hmm
so I wonder I wonder why the right wing
loves him so much yeah weird it's almost
like they project their own insecurities
desires wants problems and then say oh
you know what it's not us meanwhile
let's do this bad thing it's actually
the left the Democrats is actually these
people it's like lamps
you guys are [__] crazy
okay well I gotta get to the alpha cook
yeah because we got to get to the winner
the winners yeah yeah the Winner's easy
it's a couple Clips it's a couple and
and really the winners I almost loves
this sex trafficker or the child
trafficker I almost changed the alpha
glass to what you have on the screen
right now
oh really oh okay I almost should I
should I show what you're doing yeah
so this is um I believe
um was this the one that I I just talked
about something earlier it might have
been that one it might have been no
because I haven't retweeted this yet
I retweeted the one earlier so this is
you you posted this you found evidence
um of real men
uh kissing like Michael Knowles and Josh
Hawley here's the evidence here
that really man all right you know I
maybe May listen Josh Hawley is not
acting in this
you think he's being paid to act in this
one though like I mean maybe that's no
he's well I mean he gets obviously but
he's definitely pretending he's
definitely pretending in this picture
yeah but I'm gonna say just like he was
acting to be like Yay let's go
insurrectionist
run away it's so scary this is a moment
where you could say like I don't know
maybe Josh Hawley is also acting
this here of Michael Knowles this is a
this is an image from uh a film or
something yeah this is an image from a
video he did that's in his real uh this
is only one of the kisses there's
another one there's another [__] kiss
that he's like aggressively making out
with this girl on the bed
was doing was doing sex porno kissing
scenes with other other people than just
men yeah well here here what else is if
it was a woman he was totally
comfortable to just oh God take over
this okay the face of a of a female but
if it was a man he was like a little
hesitant oh we won't we won't touch and
you know what I'm gonna wear this this
little little mankini hey video I
wondered I wondered if that was
costuming or that's just the underwear
he happened to have on on a low budget
film they probably didn't have a lot of
costuming I think the the blue mankini
that you said in the video is
his or or rather do you think he still
wears underwear like that
[__] are you boxers are you briefs I
know I know the chat wants to know are
you boxers or bro I'm a briefs guy
briefs yeah okay I'm a briefs I got uh
you know a little little is it is it a
mankini
they're the briefs they're like a boxer
but they're you know tighter
in that closet behind him there's all
kinds of [__] in that closet there's
wigs there's puppets there's all kinds
of [__] in that in that costume closet
there behind him I almost bet I almost
bet there's some thong underwear in that
goddamn closet somewhere nope nope
there's no no are you serious what kind
what what kind of parody performer
doesn't have a pair of thongs huh I just
don't I just don't need it there's only
two ways it's either full nudity oh okay
well I mean when you're when you're so
when you when you see me in a sketch and
it's blurred out that is
and are are from are from like the Belly
Up he has either yeah look you're like
unset they're like Gabe we won't see it
[__] it doesn't matter I have to get in
right to the character this is part of
the character
oh boy oh boy okay so let's get to the
actual let's get the actual Alpha cook
uh Bethany Mandel who who
SE person no one knows you this person
racist oh really is she I said this the
other day I said this on the [__]
show I showed this clip of her I'm
talking about wokism and then the host
of Rising
um ask her this [__] video has 10
million views now here here's here's the
clip here's the clip here
um she keeps talking about woke and the
host is like hey
tell me what you think woke is watch
this lots of Americans consider
themselves very liberal
probably fewer of them consider
themselves to be woke and so you know
when when we talk about
would you mind the finding will because
it's come up a couple times I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
so
I mean woke is sort of the idea that
grab one of those books behind you you
might grab the dictionary it might help
nope this is going to be one of those
moments that goes viral yeah something
that's very hard to Define and we've
spent an entire chapter defining it yeah
it is sort of the understanding that we
need to re totally reimagine and re
reduce Society in order to create
hierarchies of Oppression
um
yep sorry I it's it's hard to explain in
a 15 second sound bite you had 30
seconds actually to explain it and you
took you took almost all 30 to mumble
around now go ahead I was gonna say this
I am surprised so whenever I go to the
hill to like get an article for what was
that
uh uh sometimes their videos like will
auto play right and people need also no
I'm not letting these co-hosts off the
hook here because people need to realize
who they are by the way so uh you've got
the the uh
uh okay uh Brianna right Brianna Joy
gray
um
so people need to remember that if you
ever hear them talk they're very Pro
Tucker Carlson and a Russia sympathizer
and so is the other [__] guy with the
glasses they wait if you're telling me
that this guy here who looks like he's
the spawn of Charlie Kirk and Tucker
Carlson like they [__] and had a baby
you're telling me this game I'm telling
you come on that those two people I mean
here I'll put on the glasses for a
second here we got the glasses oh God
you got them ready
laughs
perfect perfect shot perfect [__] oh my
God so so so they're they're they're a
little bit right yeah yeah yeah like you
know is that why she's on this program
is that why she's on this program
because no one else will take her
seriously possibly possibly I mean she
did an interview with I think it was
slate or Salon I forget which one and
they asked her about the book and it
went the same [__] way but it didn't
go viral because it wasn't on video it
was just written right a written uh
interview but she knew the moment she
knew the moment she was saying this
because this was a live broadcast there
was no turning back once yeah yeah she
was like look this is one of those
moments I'm gonna go viral yep yeah your
[__] ass yeah okay so no one knew who
she was until this moment happened here
was my commentary in a quick little bite
yeah
if I can do a quick little bite yeah
yeah is what I said was is that she
can't say what she wants to say because
what she wants to say is woke means
black people and what she means by woke
is it's a it's a it's a code word for
the hard R this is where we had a little
discussion later uh of this week when
Dustin didn't know what hard arm meant
um hard R again if you don't know what
that means just go Google it it'll pop
up it'll show you what that means it it
woke when they use it in a derogatory
sense which woke is not a derogatory
term folks only when they're using it in
this way because they're saying it's
Blackness it's black people it's the
n-word it's the hard R that's what
they're saying woke and I don't care if
they're talking about Banks I don't care
if they're talking about books I don't
care if you're talking about schools I
don't care talking about government I
don't care what they're talking about uh
trains planes and Automobiles whatever
they're calling woke they mean black
black people hard are that's what
they're saying
um and if you don't believe me because I
said that Gabe this week
not knowing who she was I didn't know
who the [__] she was and I called I
called Bethany a racist racist with with
that hard arm racist that's what I said
live on air there's tape it's provable
you can go back and look she wrote it
she wrote an op-ed in what 2017 I think
she wrote an op-ed saying how because
she's Jewish and she said and she's
married to a Jewish man too right yeah
yeah and she said we should be friend we
should connect with
uh neo-nazis
like we should extend across the eye and
and try to sympathize and understand
their position so that we can convert
them look you might find that is not
what we should do by the way that's not
what we should do by the way we are not
going to shake hands and [__] sing
Kumbaya with a bunch of [__] Nazis
okay no no no no we are not doing that
with fascists we are not trying to make
friends with them we're going to call
them out on their [__] we're gonna
call them Nazis we're gonna call them
fascists we're going to call them
exactly what they are you don't you do
not convert those people with love okay
some of those people might have an
epiphany moment later on in life right
they might see something experience
something and say oh my God what am I
doing it's possible they get a jolt to
the head you know right right something
like but it jumps ahead and then it
starts something loose yeah and you know
I I I'm you know it's crazy it has to be
said but the storm Virgil personally I
don't like Nazis we [__] hate us
right right I don't know if you noticed
I don't know War a World War
about this right right and you've got
Republicans nowadays who are like ah
fascism is it really so bad and it's
like yeah it's [__] terrible right
and the fact that you want to say oh
well we'll give them a little uh okay uh
like we'll give them the benefit of the
doubt we'll we'll think you know what
there's no doubt and there's no benefit
to doubt anything when you're talking
about Nazis I would love to see someone
say you know what I'm gonna go give them
a hug and full of love and compassion
let's see how that goes especially with
someone if you've got Nazis and you've
got a Jewish person and you say and I
think even in her op-ed she was like
look I don't have the courage to do it
oh you're gonna recommend for other
people to put their lives in safety at
risk to go befriend uh [__] Nazi
you're gonna say oh you know what hey
you guys should go over there and give
them a hug and shake their hand and take
them out to dinner and sing Kumbaya and
and be friends with them but I won't do
it we've said it many times
if there's a if there's a Nazi at a
table having dinner and 10 people sit
down and have dinner with that Nazi
there are 11 Nazis at that table and I
don't care if she's Jewish I don't give
a [__] she is a racist Nazi okay uh
Patriot takes posted these These are
tweets now these are screenshots of her
tweets now because she's likely to
probably delete a lot of these unless
she leans into this she's probably gonna
be on Fox News uh over the weekend
several times she's gonna make her her
uh Nazi rag you know roundabout here
she's gonna be in all these shows about
how oh she he's so oppressed look how
look how everyone's oppressing her
calling her a racist you go if you go
through her tweets she is like [__]
Karen oh number one she's like I went
and yelled at these people they need to
give me a customer service [__]
I mean like I got this person fired and
it's like what like are you happy about
it like a hard K Karen yeah I mean like
hard like the fact is that the thing
hard Kate it might make hard cake triple
K Karen oh there you go yeah
that's it Karen
Karen
okay Karen
um
[__] but I will say this
please tweet that later please I will
okay well uh but the fact the fact that
she tweeted these things right and maybe
she'll delete them maybe she'll lean
into and be like well people really
she's definitely gonna leave she's like
she's like people want me to be the
villain so I'm gonna be the villain it's
like no that's just who you [__] are
right you just are the villain
well here's so here's pager take says
this person who went by yeah he says
this is the person hey um if you're
wondering this is the person that went
by over being unable to Define woke
um I wonder what she means by woke you
you figure out if I was right earlier
this week when I evaluated this video on
the show if when I called her a racist
if I was correct here's one of her
tweets this is from 2012 okay so this is
from
a while back uh I find it funny that the
same people that voted to elect the
first black president are now protesting
how racist our society is hmm it seems
like she's got something against
someone you know talking about how
racist something is hmm
seems suspicious let's keep going let's
see if there's any other ones that have
any more
dripping of racism oh here's one this is
from 2012 as well the recent killing of
Trayvon Martin needs more investigation
oh okay
but where's the outrage over black on
black crime ah here it is see uh the
regular old racist tropes from Bethany
let's see if there's any more of them oh
here's another one from 2011 this goes
even further back
she's retweeting uh Josh uh house Hoskin
okay here's here's what she says
liberalism has done more to harm black
Americans uh-oh uh oh this is this is
gonna get bad while trying to help then
the cake K cake KKK has done while
trying to kill them oh my God so she
literally is a Karen
Karen this is I'm we're gonna read it to
you again liberalism has done more to
harm black people in Black Americans
while trying to help then the KKK has
done while trying to kill them
what the actual [__] is she talking
about other than oh
black people need to be conservative I
think that's what she's trying to say
here is that what she's trying to I mean
I I was going through one of them and
says if you read one thing on the
hashtag Trayvon Martin case today let it
be this from March 26 2012. I click the
link but unfortunately the website
doesn't exist anymore so then I went to
Wayback machine right I plugged it in
it's human events powerful conservative
voices
a media show trial and basically it
sounds like the disproportionate
response to a scuffle and the Hasty
drawing of conclusions about a young man
he knew nothing about are among George
Zimmerman's sins they're among the sins
of George Zimmerman's denouncers too
right and it goes to his whole thing and
it was black on black murders that's you
know and at that point you're like okay
I know exactly where this is this
article this op-ed is going to go here
in what argument you're trying to make
right the idea that you're trying to
then excuse some what about is and to be
like oh what about black on black crime
guys that's pretty bad and it's like
the fact that your first response is to
say but black people but black people
instead of being like wow this is
terrible a teenager was killed by a what
we learned later on
uh about this racist guy who who who
lied about a story Zimmerman killed it
murdered this kid Trayvon Martin
and it's just it's just gross you know
and it's like [__] man these people
try to excuse and be like wow but what
about this other minority group they do
bad stuff too and it's like why is that
your first response I mean I know why it
is but the reason why we know her this
week is because she couldn't describe on
a live feed of what woke is and the
reason why is because she can't really
say what it is because if she says what
it is it undermines the entire the
entire reason why they're saying it
because it's code words we knew that CRT
was code word CRT with CRT all they're
doing the CRT map and the CRT this and
CRT that it meant black people with the
hard art that's what they were talking
about and then it got smashed into
pieces because the entire country went
wait wait wait CRT is that's not what
that is right that's and the entire
country got wise to what it actually was
so then they moved on to woke now I
believe woke they're losing the plot on
woke and Rhonda santis is doing a great
job at losing the plan of woke and
they're moving to this dni Dei excuse me
Dei is going to be the next CRT in the
next wokism they're going to say Dei is
the is the thing that's destroying
America and they mean they mean because
it means diversity equity and inclusion
it means black people that's that's what
they mean folks that's what Bethany
means that's what Rhonda santis means
that's what all these [__]
James comer means that's what Jim Jordan
means that's what Marjorie Taylor green
Steve Bannon anyone who says the word
woke in a derogatory way means black
people that are Black Culture black
society Blackness that is what they're
talking about like I have I have friends
you know uh people who work in Human
Resources right and in that they work on
Dei right they want to make sure that
everyone's voice is heard they want to
make sure that there is inclusion right
there is diversity that they do have the
ability to make sure that these people
who historically haven't had a voice
haven't had the ability to speak up or
have their voice heard now have an
aspect of their you know DNA in the
company right you've got important
decisions that are being made you have a
committee of people who are a diverse
group
who can say based on their experience
knowledge education what have you to say
oh you know what it'd be great if we did
this or we should consider this it's
just it is not it's not you know it's
God it's so irritating the fact that one
Republicans don't know what it means and
when they do know what it means they're
in court right you've got uh the
attorney of of Ron DeSantis in court
literally defining the actual definition
of woke when asked what is woke right
what is wokeness right is the injustices
that are happening uh in in our country
right the people that are
disproportionately affected by this
right a marginalized Community who
doesn't have the same uh accessibility
rights uh Equity uh that that others
have
and calling that out right calling it
out but to Republicans like oh well
I there's one thing I meant to say
earlier
is you've got Bethany Mandel right
she goes uh we wrote a whole chapter on
this right she has a finished book right
a finish she wrote a book she wrote it
she wrote it with someone else right she
wrote Of course
she even says in the clip that we showed
she goes ah we wrote a whole chapter on
this
then why can't you describe it then it's
also why do you need a whole [__]
chapter well that's true you know well
because but they they have to justify
their hate that's why they need a whole
[__] Championship right well they
have this long ways to circumvent you
know logic and rationale and I mean you
know just human behavior right they're
like oh well The Logical representation
of the human humanitarian aspect of how
Society really views one individual to
all right Shapiro all right Ben Shapiro
it's just big words it's fluff big words
it doesn't mean anything it goes to show
you that these people are [__] idiots
right right and they can't
even when asked directly what is woke
right they've had a whole whole
opportunity to write a chapter in a
[__] book to to deliver this news and
she's promoting the book on the show and
she has the ability the ability to learn
right does she well I mean okay but if
she's saying oh you know what I had a
whole chapter on this about what woke is
or we're trying to Define it it's like
we're still trying to Define it like
it's like this elusive thing out there
like the [__] Yeti well that's why
they have to that's what they have to
have that's what they have to have but
speaking of the Yeti oh man that's a
great transition I saw her and I saw her
speaking of the Yeti speaking of the
Yeti we really got to get to the winner
of this week's bone of the week and you
know she's undefeated here
on the bonehead of the week pole
representative if you want to call her
that Marjorie Taylor hoof foot Petty
Yeti green
is our winner she does a lot of
bone-headed stuff a lot a lot a lot a
lot and there's a few Clips but we were
talking about Vladimir Putin uh being a
child trafficker earlier and this person
claims she doesn't like traffickers but
listen to what she says about her hero
Vladimir Putin in this clip we're paying
for a war a proxy war with Russia when
I've never seen Putin actually show in
any detail his plans to invade Europe no
one has shown me that so I don't believe
the lies that I'm being told about this
wait wait wait does she wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait just
a minute just a [__] minute does she
not know
does she not know where Ukraine is
hold on let me hey Siri
where is Ukraine
it showed me on the map it's not going
to tell me did she not know did she
really not know that Ukraine
is part of um
well we're going to fact check this
again I don't know if this is right hold
on hey Siri
is Ukraine in Europe
the answer I found is Europe damn it
it's in Europe oh man oh let's let's
watch this again because I want to make
sure I heard her correct here let's
listen let's listen we're paying for a
war a proxy war with Russia when I've
never seen Putin actually show in any
detail his plans to invade Europe no yep
that's what that's what she said that's
what she said
this stupid [__] [__] I reserve that
word for her uh I'm very careful about
that word but maybe that's what got me
kicked off in the seven days suspension
but Jesus [__] Christ are you kidding
me are you kidding me oh boy are you
serious
Taylor green
said six billion people cross the border
illegally right she likes the word
billions yeah she loves it she said five
billion dollars went to one school
a Grade School in Illinois to teach CRT
she also thinks that uh 4.8
000 pounds is is better right than 11.2
000 pounds of fentanyl seized at the
border she goes uh Trump got 4.8 Biden
got 11.2 Biden bad Trump good so if she
if those are magnomics
what is the geography of Mega because
she's getting that wrong yeah you know
what I mean because that's meganomics
yeah yeah yeah so now we gotta get okay
so geography so uh
uh oh man that's a good question yeah we
have to have a word for this because we
got meganomics yeah yeah and that is the
um now I'll show you you know speaking
of seas at the border while you're
thinking of that speaking of seas at the
border there was apparently an incident
where a little
um ball of sand in a duct tape and duct
tape oh yeah yeah I heard about that I
think I was leaving yeah I was leaving
Mexico yeah because there was a few
there was a couple things that happened
while I was in Mexico
this was one of them this is one of our
bone-headed we
um and apparently where this was found
um was confidential information and the
reason why it's confidential is because
how they were surveilling and who they
were surveilling in that area and how
they know what this moment reminds me of
Geraldo
when he when he you mean Geraldo
oh yeah
Geraldo Rivera Gerald Gerald
Jerry Rivera yeah he's his cousin uh
this is more evidence that uh that gave
Sanchez may or may not speak Spanish
yeah
also I've made the same mistake and it's
it that my hillbilly is rubbing off yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty good uh no
Geraldo Rivera yeah I mean not you know
not the whole uh Al Capone moment right
but the going and revealing where the
military operation for the U.S military
was right on TV and so here here we are
right here are these terrorist stories
look at this confidential information
I'm gonna broadcast live so apparently
the confidential information in this
case
um was that the United States was
surveilling the cartel in this
particular area for certain things she
was briefed on that
um but she kind of put her three toes in
her mouth here listen listen to
what or Ortez says to Marjorie Taylor
green after she spills confidential
information listen to this
Chief Ortiz are you aware that there was
an explosive device found by border
patrol agents on January 17th in an area
called No Man's Land okay so the
explosive device
um they treated as explosive advice in
the beginning because they weren't sure
what it is so that's why they treat it
that way because you know you don't know
what it is she might as well treat it as
the most dangerous thing you can treat
us but once they've found out what it
was which was a bag of sand duck with
duct tape around it right um she knows
that she's been briefed on this she
knows that because
right right I think she waves it around
and she knows where it was found the
detail that she doesn't want to reveal
because obviously wants to play to the
fear mongering is exactly what was
revealed right well but the problem is
is that she reveals information that
she's really not supposed to
um let's watch and there's surveillance
of who put it there there it is and
guess what it wasn't Americans it was
cartels here it is
this is hilarious watch this shut the
[__] up lady and good to see you again I
will tell you that uh some of this
information that I receive I receive in
a a confidential uh skiff so I'm gonna
be a little hesitant of briefing what I
know and what I don't know with respect
to some of those an event like that in
other words hey lady you just spilled
confidential information in a [__] in
a hearing yeah that the cartel can hear
you dumbass and now you've given us
you've given us away in this area where
we're surveilling them and they don't
know that now they do know that because
you're an idiot and you're divulging
confidential information because you
think it's a gotcha when it's not I got
you there's a bag of sand you [__]
idiot watch your response though one of
the most bone-ended things I've seen in
a long time her do and boy does she have
competition for bone-headed things she
does watch this I understand Chief Ortiz
but I'm not going to be confidential
because I think people deserve to know
what the [__] it's not listen that's why
it's confidential you dumbass yeah but
you have to realize that she also is
under the belief that Donald Trump
stealing classified documents and taking
up the Mar-A-Lago and holding them in
his [__] desk and then showing them
off to people who come into his office
with his little Mount Rushmore plus
Trump thing like you have to realize
that she's under the belief that
everything that Donald Trump took to
Mar-A-Lago is his so the fact that she
goes oh let you know what I'm not going
to be confidential because I believe the
American people need to know
she's got a decent Q Anon Point here
right bear with me bear with me on this
Q Anon logic here if the Q Anon logic is
that Donald J Trump is the mango
Mussolini Jesus right he's the chosen
one and he can declassify documents and
classify information with his mind maybe
maybe he was on the phone with her
before this hearing and she said hey you
know I Got This Confidential piece of
information that I want to let out in
the public that I really shouldn't could
you go ahead and use your mind and
declassify it for me while we're on the
phone she very well might have been like
me I mean maybe that's Donald Trump's on
the phone he's like oh my God
uh
just BR every time
you know just breathing in and every
time he does that there's a there's a
moment of one more document being
Declassified because he thought of it
but again marjor Taylor green how
[__] dumb is she to go you know what
oh no
how dumb is she I mean you want to know
how dumb she is is that a scale that we
can actually create uh well let me show
you another clip here and maybe this
will give you an idea how [__] dumb
she is talking about cartels listen to
this crazy ass [__] out there drumming
the the you know beating the drum for
war every single day in Ukraine when the
real drum we should be beating for war
is the one against the Mexican cartels
because that's the one I'm beating
oh my God you can't make this up listen
Ukraine didn't want to go to war no one
is no one was clamoring for Russia to
invade Ukraine a Sovereign Nation you
[__] buffoon and and frankly no one
wants to have to defend Ukraine they
want Russia to go the [__] home and stop
committing war crimes that's why they
have an arrest warrant for that
[__] your your favorite dictator
in the world today the idea that she's
like oh you know what well I mean like
you know you've got other Republicans
also that are uh Defenders the great
Defenders the great Republican Defenders
of [__] Vladimir Putin
and she's one of them right she's one of
these people that believe like oh
Vladimir Putin you mean the same
Vladimir Putin who's a child trafficker
is that the one you're talking about
that's the one okay I just want to make
sure and even last year I mean like not
only not only just this aspect of of
trafficking children right kidnapping
and stealing you innocent Ukrainian
children kids were like I'm just trying
to live my life and Vladimir Putin's
like I'm gonna bomb the [__] out of your
country unless you let me have it
and even last year right the party of we
have to save the children
Vladimir Putin was [__] bombing
hospitals okay bombing hospitals working
train stations even there were there
were families mothers
kids like this whole aspect of save the
children is complete [__] okay it is
utter [__] and whenever you have
Margaret Taylor green or one of these
other Vladimir Putin simps out there
trying to be like you know what we're
giving too much money to [__] Ukraine
it's the same argument that they try to
make when it comes to oh well what about
black on black crime what about you know
Latino and Latino crime right let's not
talk about these white people committing
crimes that is what they're doing it's
always whataboutism it's always this
aspect of like
okay yeah okay with that being said what
about this other thing you know it's
constantly deflection it's constantly
projection it's constantly proving to
that that this group this this anti-woke
anti-uh
uh minority
anti-lgbtq group
is just trying to make themselves
feel better
by playing victim by projecting by being
Hypocrites by not actually believing in
the things that they claim
to believe in right that this part of
their core principles as a Christian
Republican
it's [__] right and we know that and
that's what we do here on the show we
call it out every day
and especially on bonehead of the week
that's right because she is undefeated
of bone end of the week there is a
reason for it because she's a [__]
bonehead Marjorie Taylor green oh you
never fail never fails and I think the
audience honestly they saw Marjorie say
they're green on there like I want to go
for this other guy she has more but she
has not lost she won which by the way
yeah before we get to the last bit I'm
sure there's something else you're going
to show but I do it is no I'm I'm
looking for something but I really don't
have anything we're waiting at a time
yeah we got a few minutes left it is
that time of year
bonehead
of the week March Madness
bonehead matters today's I think the
first day okay of the games so so you're
gonna post this on the um
so yeah we'll have the bracket it'll
probably be most likely the same people
as last year but there might be a few
new ones we'll see
I'm good we're good it's going to be
let's give today's winner this week's
winner
her do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Marge you never fail
never disappoint well apparently we're
gonna have bonehead Madness so be
watching uh the at Tony Michaels pod on
Twitter I think we could probably be
posting it on YouTube too right you know
what we're gonna do yeah so go make sure
to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast YouTube channel go over to the
community tab you'll find all the polls
there for um bonehead Madness as he
posts them on Twitter I'll post them on
YouTube so you can find them download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google
oh God she never disappoints she's such
a [__] idiot you know like I you
remember I talked about I I it's crazy
but I talked about uh Marshall
Blackburn's washing machine [__] this
week oh yeah and I had to bring up
Michelle Bachmann and then it made me
think of Sarah Palin and then I think of
Lauren bobert but then I'm like do any
of those hold a candle how [__] dumb
Marjorie Taylor green is I don't know
it's it would be a great competition
really I really would holy [__] I mean
just bone-headed [__] just the
dumbest people in Congress
and they're some of the loudest people
uh unfortunately too so thanks thanks
for joining us Ramona week everyone if
you're on the podcast stick around we're
gonna have some uh announcements right
after this
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
of the week
oh man Madge Madre Taylor
what do you got going on with this
bonehead Madness we're gonna start it up
today you said yeah so yeah sorry the
game started yesterday forgot about that
but oh yeah I remember last year we've
got the Sinister 16. we've got the
hateful eight the deplorable four right
and then you come down
to the final two the final two Madness
the bonehead Champion there was a Bonet
Champion so be watching for those polls
so you'll be able to vote in all those
brackets
um and it will probably do the same I
think we'll do the same breakdown which
is U.S senators right U.S
representatives sure lame stream media
lame stream media and [__] waffles okay
well swamp waffles Works wasn't that
didn't I name that category I think yeah
I was like we remember some outliers
yeah there was like outliers that
weren't like in a member of
the team like senators or
Representatives so I'm like yeah I'll
call them [__] waffles that's what they
are but yeah we've got some new people
like yeah you know last year was Tucker
Carlson Sean Hannity Candace Owens and
Charlie Kirk for Lancaster media but
this year oh I could actually replace a
couple people sure sure Michael Knowles
is in there for sure yeah Matt Walsh
he's a good Contender for this for the
uh Sinister 16. that's for sure that's
the show or you can throw some of those
in [__] waffle category too you know
yeah yeah yeah you know they're not
really a member of a team they're just
outliers [__] boxes you know Nazi
[__] hey I got I got a few
announcements and I know you probably do
too
um patreon news I'm gonna do an ask me
anything after the show I've got to do
an edit and post it but I'm gonna keep
in touch with you over on patreon we're
gonna do an ask me anything it'll be a
30 minute live it'll be a private live
so if you want to ask me any question
that you can I mean any question at all
I'll answer them maybe
um but no you can come to the ask me
anything just go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or go to the Tony michaels.com
find the patreon if you want to
participate in that this afternoon it'll
be within the next hours when we'll
start and so if you can hear me out
there um and you're a patreon member
right now we would the link will be up
soon after the broadcast here as I'm
editing I'll make the link
um so you can come join that private
link but if you're if you're not a
member of patreon but you want to come
see what asked me
um anything is about and you can go to
patreon you can join for five dollars
I'm opening up to everyone today so
everyone on patreon to be able to
um see then ask me anything did you have
any news on your patreon yeah yeah so I
will be having uh there'll be a Lauren
or another margin Taylor green there's
going to be uh
bonehead coming out that's I meant to
edit when I was in Mexico but I was
traveling too busy so I should be having
that one you were drinking too much beer
and eating too much tacos don't lie to
us we know we know yes there will be one
on Margaret Taylor green coming up
coming up next
um there will be uh this Sunday I'm
going to do a bigger uh I typically do
them for the producers on on Sundays
like when I can uh but I think this week
I'm gonna open it up and have uh more
people come in so if you're not show up
you know it's gonna be great this week
I'm going to do it on Michael Knowles so
we're gonna have a little viewing party
of Michael Knowles and his his song for
acting so yeah show up we'll [__] run
the jokes on this guy uh I'll probably
do it at like go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez to get some uh and also go
to what was that show.com you can find
it there as well but I think probably
noon Pacific time I'll do one it'll be
about Michael Knowles and we'll get to
watch this shitty
shitty shitty acting because I found
some good ones
I don't know if you're gonna turn people
away Drag Me with Michael knows acting
but I I know I know I tried to keep the
audience here when I was playing that
video today oh my God
straight trash that independent film was
uh but you know that's how don't worry
we're gonna watch the full film and some
other Clips how long is the uh that one
the full short is like 10 minutes oh
okay the real is a few other like
there's a ton of clips that I found so
get ready for the worst I it's actually
worst best you've ever seen the worst
acting you've ever seen is typically
categorized it's as a Razzie so we'll
give Michael knows a Razzie or whatever
is lower than a Razzie for the
performances we're gonna watch on Sunday
I don't know if you can get lower than
Michael knows or rezzy all right
everyone uh it's Friday we appreciate
you um being with us this week we're
glad Gabe is back here on the Tony
Michaels podcast make sure to subscribe
you'll be here all week next week I'm
assuming unless he loses power he didn't
you know George Soros doesn't pay his
power bill over there for him uh follow
us on Twitter Tony Michaels pod download
every single episode on Apple's Spotify
Google if you're on Facebook right now
or still have a Facebook account go join
us on Facebook at the Tony Michaels and
make sure to subscribe to the up wires
YouTube channel they helped us out
through our suspension the upwire.com or
go to YouTube and just search the up
wire and subscribe to their Channel and
also by the way if you want to give us
some of Jeff Bezos money do that here's
what you do you take your Amazon Prime
account your Amazon Prime account and
you link it to a Twitch account
and could you get one free subscription
Gabe Sanchez to Twitch if you have an
Amazon Prime account and then you just
give us that twitch
um or the Amazon Prime free account and
you just link your Twitch account in
your Amazon Prime account and we get
money uh Jeff Bezos is money so we get
billionaire money if you do that so if
you want to do that and also uh be
looking for all the patreon stuff on
Gabe's patreon and my patreon again I'm
gonna do and ask me anything uh after
the show here in about an hour or so and
the game's gonna do its thing on Sunday
so go to patreon.com the Tony Michaels
or patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez
follow this there oh and by the way
we you guys bought a ton of [__] em hats
this week so if you ordered a [__]
hat they are on their way I've seen a
lot of orders going out being shipped
out from our provider uh the [__]
hats and again I will leave that open
until Sunday the promo code hats 10
that's hats 10 you go to hats.d Tony
michaels.com or just go to the attorney
michaels.com scroll down you'll see the
[__] them hat store click on there use
the promo code hats10 that's hats
h-a-t-s-10 and get 10 off your tire [__]
em hat order I'll keep that on till
Sunday
have a great weekend
won't do anything I wouldn't do for St
Pat's day which much so just have some
green beer called a day oh I'm getting
wasted tonight that's right I will be
hungover tomorrow folks have a safe uh
St Pat's day have a safe weekend
everyone will be back here on Monday
same time same place Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon